Okay.
Well,
good experience.
Good googly Mowgli.
Bert Kreischer.
Hello everybody.
This is our fifth year anniversary.
Happy anniversary to us.
Uh,
Burt crushes here,
so yes,
will,
we will be imbibing and libations.
And as soon as Jamie gets us to fucking whiskey,
what are you doing,
Jamie?
We didn't make it.
Sure he knows what he's doing.
He basically Shit,
not really
bird Christ.
I'm fine.
How are you my friend?
So glad we're doing this today.
I haven't slept in like three days.
Excellent.
Tawang ballerup malaria pills.
Oh,
are you fucking with my head,
man?
Dude,
Dave Foley was on malaria pills and I had to keep him from attacking a reporter.
Oh,
that's what I fucking heard about it.
Cause I heard about malaria pills before I started taking them and I was like,
these are bad news.
Right?
And then some people have adverse reactions.
If you drank alcohol while you've been on them,
well,
you're not supposed to do that.
I don't think.
Oh,
a well,
how much was going to sleep at the hallucinations?
I think,
um,
that was the issue with Dave.
I don't think you're supposed to drink when you're on that stuff.
Explain a lot.
Yeah.
I think it has,
uh,
some pretty negative impacts.
What's the name of the malaria medicine?
We'll Google it.
There's a little med,
I don't want to say it.
The delirium or Larry Medicine.
They uh,
it's fucking,
the dreams are insane.
I mean,
I'm already a really active dreamer,
but dreaming on malaria medication.
That's one of the first,
Google those malaria medicine and alcohol.
Malaria drugs and avoidance of alcohol.
Yeah.
It just shows you what a fucking friendly drunk I am.
Even on malaria pills,
I didn't get any trouble.
Yeah.
This is funny.
People are complaining.
They're like,
I was just reading that anyone taking drugs for protection against malaria
should not drink alcohol.
What a vacation would it be if I can't drink?
So like the guy,
like I'm in the fucking Sudan.
How am I going to sleep at night?
What are the vacation that would be,
if I could drink,
this is exactly how I felt.
I can't have any,
your doctors told you this.
I don't think I will take it.
We'd rather have a little fun and take the risk then be miserable.
This motherfucker is more interested in getting drunk.
Then he is catching malaria,
which has ready for it killed half the people that have ever died ever in the
history of the human race.
Are you having the people who have ever died ever have died from malaria?
That's where is that on that?
I heard it on the Internet.
No,
no.
I heard it from the radio lab,
from the radio lab podcast.
There was a woman on her who was talking about malaria and mosquitoes.
Great Radio Lab.
Does their work.
No,
they don't.
They,
they talked about quicksand
porn and I cannot find one.
Really?
Yeah.
They talked about quicksand porn.
The guys that are in it,
they called sinkers and I was like,
fuck,
I've never,
I've seen it all.
I thought and I was like,
I'm going to find quick porn.
I can't find it anywhere.
You're not looking hard enough so I've got your number that you're fucking in
quicksand.
I think.
I'm not certain how it works cause I can't find it.
This is true.
Listen to this one.
Out of every two people who have ever died of died of malaria,
this is from national geographic.
Holy Shit.
What was the,
here's the question though.
What's the,
what's the percentage of people that die?
They get malaria.
Listen to this.
About 3.2 billion people.
Almost half the world's population are at risk of malaria.
Oh,
it's,
it's anywhere.
It's all over the fucking place.
I'm getting back on the medication in two weeks.
This is insane.
This is a,
this is one of those really weird things that kills a shitload of people and
we're kind of immune to it.
We don't get it much over here.
So we,
we don't give a fuck about malaria.
Like no one's,
everyone is so terrified about Ebola because it came over here.
Oh my God.
They brought their dirty disease to America.
My God.
But nobody talks about fucking malaria.
Malaria is terrifying.
Bert.
Quick same port.
Shut up.
He found it.
Will you pass me that link?
Wow.
This is crazy,
man.
Yeah,
you want to,
you want it another scary ones.
Rabies.
Once you get rabies,
you're dead.
Listen to these numbers.
Ready for this shit.
2013 there were 198 million malaria cases with an uncertainty range of 124
million to 283 months.
So that means that when they say one 98 and maybe as low as 1:24 AM I be as high
as 283 so like this is the kind of infrastructure you're dealing with.
I mean,
you're dealing like insanely impoverished areas,
right?
Okay.
It says an estimated 584,000 malaria deaths with an uncertainty range of between
three 67 and seven 55 so it might be as low as 300 because they're uncertain
about the numbers of whether 500 million or 584 million is accurate.
So it could be as low as 367 million,
367,000 rather or as high as 755,000 so as many as 755 they'll just,
let's go with the lowest number.
366 or 367,000 that's the low number of their uncertainty range.
The mansion that many people dying of a fucking disease in a year.
367,000 that's amazing.
That's like a 13 football stadiums,
Sunday packed game only you
would think that way.
How many is,
is it 100,000
that gets into those ball games?
So the big ones,
like Florida state was I think like thirty five thousand eighty five thousand a
football stadium full of people.
I think they get bigger.
Like what's the youngest one?
What's the like Dallas stadium 60 or something,
right.
I want to say death valley is really fucking big.
I know Ohio state's like,
I want to say,
I have to say it's like a hundred thousand there's gotta be some that are like
100,000 right?
Well,
how much?
Hundred Five Ohio state.
I am fucking so proud when it should be.
You should be honored.
But that's a,
that's a big fucking number of people.
300 plus thousand people dead of a disease and no one even talks about it cause
we don't get it here.
Yeah,
it was in Calabasas.
He imagined in fucking malaria made its way to bel air.
How much people would be freaking out.
White people would be losing their shit.
Everyone would be on a medication.
What's amazing is you're right Pete,
the callousness,
I mean we'd go to the farm state where we're talking about,
and I had people on my crew just hop off of the malaria medicine.
They're like,
I can't deal with it.
And I was like,
my director at Paul was like,
you know,
cause if you skip a day,
you're fucked.
You got to take it every day,
two days before you're in the area while you're in the area.
And then seven days after the area,
dude,
fuck all that.
Fuck all that.
I'm invaluable.
It's still taking malaria pills.
God dammit malaria.
It sounds like something you'd order with breakfast,
malaria.
Would it be a drink or it'd be like a jam.
It's something from the south.
Oh,
I'll get some malaria on the side.
Can I get some malaria with my grits?
Did does,
you're right.
Malaria fucked up disease man.
That is a crazy statistic that one out of two people that have ever died ever
died of malaria.
And you want another real shit.
One is den,
gay fever.
How can it be shittier than that?
Because you get half covered.
They got half the deaths covered.
How's it going to be worse?
No,
no,
no.
I think the disease,
getting the disease,
you get it.
You're just like,
you're like sick as fuck for like three weeks.
Then it goes away for a month and it comes back 10 times worse.
And so,
you know,
that shit's around the corner.
You feel better and you're like,
fuck,
it's just going to give bad why it's so it gets good and then it gets bad ever
with everyone.
But uh,
yeah.
Well I don't know why I shouldn't say things but,
but yeah,
by my cameraman.
Got It.
And he and he got an Africa and then,
and I got,
I got the dengue fever shot,
I got Japanese encephalitis,
Hep Bay,
have bee,
I got all of them.
We had a,
we had a guy,
um,
that um,
does our podcast,
Justin wren and uh,
he was supposed to be here.
He,
he does a lot of work in Africa and he was in Africa doing this stuff with
pygmies.
He sets up a wells for the matches.
He used to fight in the UFC,
went to,
went to the Congo,
fell in love with these pygmies.
Just they're like the nicest people that you like,
feels dedicated to helping them.
So he has like this foundation called fight for the forgotten,
puts all this money towards building wells and we even donate some money and we,
we had a bitcoin people,
they donated money to my bitcoin and I matched whatever they donated and we sent
him some money to help them with wells and shit.
Anyway,
point being,
he's supposed to be on last week,
but he was sick and I was like,
no,
you could stay home for a little bit too much.
And he's like,
well,
I've been home for two weeks,
so whatever,
it's can't be bowl.
I'm like,
I just,
the fact that you had it tell me that too.
So you stay the fuck home for a little bit fella.
It was,
I'll tell you what,
last night we were at the hospital with Eila until like six in the morning.
I was telling these guys and they tested her for the flu and she felt like she
got the flu the second they came back with that,
they shut the doors,
they put signs on the door and anyone that entered her exit wore a mask.
Wow.
And I was like,
man,
the dehumanization of that moment.
And then when she went to leave,
they put a mask on her and she looked at me and she was like,
it was going like really out of it.
But like why are they doing this to me?
Almost like have I been affected?
Am I,
am I getting separated from the pack?
And that feeling and I looked at her,
I was like,
it's Paparazzi baby.
Cause she would laughed.
And then my wife took her and I stayed and got an Uber.
Well,
you know the done.
That's cool man.
The,
um,
the number of people that die from the flu is pretty staggering.
Fuck.
If you ever look at that,
the number of people that die from the flu,
I was,
I was really shocked.
I was like,
wow,
you know,
we don't think about it because it's something that everybody gets,
it's like once every couple of years are gonna have the flu.
I get the flu like every other year.
It seems like,
I don't think I get it.
No,
no.
Cause I get a flu shot.
Yeah,
I do.
I do get flu shots,
but,
um,
I also get like,
I don't,
I don't know really what the flu is technically.
Like,
is it a chest cold?
Is it throwing up sweating?
Like just buckets of sweat and you're just fevers,
chills,
fevers,
chills.
I've the plug on the flute.
I've never gotten the flu once.
Take a guess as to how many people you think die.
All right,
we're talking about 370 million.
I think it's 3:00 PM three.
Oh,
seven 50,000 for 350 million.
Oh yeah.
Three w the low number area for malaria is three 37 three 37 I wanna say one
2,525 America.
Oh Shit.
Uh,
25th fifty thousand fifty thousand what do you think Brian?
Hundred and 50,036 36,000 oh six 36 pussies.
Lot of it's like 31 more than have died from Ebola.
I mean,
how many fucking people would die from Ebola?
From America,
but a few people got it over there,
came back.
But I,
I'm pretty sure they've all been treated right.
I think one died.
One died.
Yeah.
I think,
no,
let's find out that how many people died.
I don't think anybody died.
How many people died from Ebola in America,
by the way,
if this was a statistical in skydiving,
I could jump right in with the actual odds.
I've,
I'd Google that every time before I go skydiving.
The skydiving thing is scary.
I think it's 43 this year.
It was 48 two years ago.
Oh,
dad's friend
died.
So that alone is just too close.
You know,
like I know somebody who's know somebody that died so nope.
Yeah.
How did he die?
Malaria.
Skydiving.
It was a woman and it gets her her right or her chutes got tangled up.
There was one death in the USA last year.
Four people got it and one person died from the flu from Ebola.
Oh.
So,
um,
I'm assuming that means that they were there when they got it,
but that might not be the case.
They might have been dealing with somebody who had it when they came back.
I'm assuming they had to be there,
come home with it.
And I think our,
I think it was the first patient and he was patient zero cause the next one was
a doctor in Atlanta,
if I'm not mistaken.
And I only say that because,
uh,
I remember hearing the news say something about if you can track it early,
like the,
all the nurses,
they caught it in Texas.
They got it and they were on top of it.
They were like,
Oh shit,
I'm not feeling good.
I got Ebola.
Right.
They,
they jumped on it and got treat.
What did,
what is the treatment,
you know,
I mean,
well they just,
they must give you a lot of liquids and keep Ya.
I'd imagine it's keeping the keeping.
I'm sure.
What is the killer is the fever because you know,
that was the,
that's the big fear is if Phoebe gets over one or four,
we're talking brain damage and,
and start cooking.
Yeah.
And so I'd imagine that's what it is.
And you can't lower the fever,
which is amazing that people can live in Phoenix,
you know,
or Vegas.
Really fucking fascinating.
Yeah.
Vegas is fucking insane.
In the summer,
like you're walking around in the summer,
it's 120 degrees out.
Like what the fuck is,
what does 108 who stopped here?
Why did you guys stop her?
You stopped here.
You get a pump,
all your water from Colorado.
You get this crazy fucking system where you have a,
this,
this Goddamn goddammit monolith in the,
in the middle of the desert that has neon that's lit 24 hours a day.
You have extreme energy demands.
You've mother fuckers built like this is a crazy spot to build.
You know the the only reason why it was built there at all,
because it was built by mobsters gambling,
right?
Yeah.
But the,
the idea was like,
hey,
we'll just make mean,
think about how crazy they were when they made Vegas.
We're going to make a wild fucking place with very few laws.
Just make it so it's four hours drive to get out there from La.
Like you're not really going to drive like,
especially back those days,
those old rickety ass cars.
Can you imagine what a fucking commitment it was to go to Vegas in 1950 and
[inaudible] 55 bel air
on the roads,
the roads back then dog shit.
How shitty the fucking right.
I guarantee you.
Part of that was w was still dirt
dog shit.
Roads,
dog shit cars,
no radio.
No.
If they had a radio,
air conditioning is suspect.
What,
what radio stations make it all the way the fuck out the middle of the desert
and they probably had weak ass signals back then and they probably only want
worked for a few miles when phone.
Yeah,
if you got lucky,
you went up to
a place that had a dial phone,
you know?
Oh you,
oh you better pack your fucking water because there's at least a two hour
stretch that there is no one.
Not only that,
you're most likely you're going to need extra water for your fucking car anyway
because that bitch is going to overheat because the radiators sucked in those
old pieces of shit.
But he knew how to fix one though.
That was the difference.
Like if you pulled into a gas station back then and you know you had a 1955
Chevy,
they would go,
oh look here.
Your uh,
your spark plugs bad,
the alternator's not working.
You've got,
this is a,
I could see right here,
your,
your brake fluids low.
Now you open up like a 2015 Cadillac,
you open up the hood.
You're like,
what am I looking at?
I have no idea what any of this says.
This is all just a big computer grid.
What's that black box in the corner?
Fuck is all this.
What's the thing that says Nsa that's on the hood?
What is this black thing is this is following me.
I tried to change my daughter's back tire than one attached to the chain
yesterday and I was like sitting there going,
how the fuck did I do this?
I was like,
I know that this should be something that's in my skillset.
Right,
but it's just not here anymore.
I remember how to put one back on.
Remember when you chain would pop off and you used to have to get your fingers
up in there and figuring out how to put that fucker back.
Kids today,
they don't have to worry about this shit.
Carl Brown wrote the tip of his finger off that way.
Who?
Corey Brown kid in your neighborhood near the,
I play baseball with,
oh,
well one of the only black dudes that our school,
but at the tip of his finger was gone.
Oh Wow.
And he does it from putting a chain back on and he did that thing and food
finger got caught sliced on you.
When you're around a bunch of hard men like lumber Jack type characters,
you're always going to find missing fingers.
There's always a dude who's missing a digit or a piece or something.
Something got chopped off in a wood saw or something got stuck under a rock and
they end up fucking break it off.
Do you know how sad that would make me if I lost my finger?
Cause like I,
you just think that's,
that's me forever now.
I no longer have that little piece of way better than losing a lot of shit.
I'll take a finger all day.
I lost,
I lost all my teeth,
all of them except for eight that are in my mouth off here.
I'll show you my eighth.
They're still my mouth and you'll be like,
what happened?
Fuck.
Why bad teeth to begin with?
Like I,
you know,
math hereditary.
My mom,
mom's on Methadone.
I was on math and smoking and dry.
No,
but,
uh,
I had bad teeth to begin with.
And then on my 11th birthday I got hit in the mouth with a baseball bat.
Oh,
Jesus.
Whipped back teeth and it not.
It broke all the ones in the front and chipped all the ones in the back.
Will you just in the wrong place at the wrong time and the kid was swinging or
no.
W I was catcher,
a pass ball.
I stopped it.
Throw my mask off,
throw the guy out at third and the guy,
the batter trying to break the play up,
thought he'd hit me with the bat.
We're fucking 11 I don't know where the competition in this kid's house was,
but oh my God.
For you in the head with a bat to stop the fuck and play,
I guess.
I know a little psycho.
It was my birthday too and annual and there's something fucking crazy.
My Dad kept me in the game until the was over.
God moved me over to shortstop because we were short players and he couldn't
stop someone out in the fourth inning.
He was your dad,
the coach that was the fucking coach.
And I was like,
and I went into the blocker,
into the,
dug out.
My Dad's like,
buddy,
I need Jack shortstop.
And I was like,
and that's not my dad.
I mean,
I guess it is my dad,
but it's not my,
I never met teeth missing 20.
I don't 26 or something fell out.
26 teeth fell out right there.
No,
26 were damaged.
And so there are just fell out right there after he got hit in the face with a
bat.
Like you knew you were fucked up.
Uh,
well,
definitely all the ones up front and all the ones gone.
They were on home plate.
And your dad made you still fucking,
yeah,
I saw my dad.
He's like,
well,
I mean we're going to lose game,
you know?
Wow.
Yeah.
That's a good way to fuck up a kid.
Turned them into a comedian.
Yeah.
Well that's how you fuck up a person.
You can't be normal and become a comedian.
But uh,
and so all my teeth are veneers are bonded or crowns or posts and crowns.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's harsh dude.
That's why I look at guys,
the guys in the UFC who fight and and no one ever loses teeth.
I'm always shocked at that.
So my teeth are super vulnerable.
Like if you,
if I got hit in the mouth with a piece of plastic fruit in high school and it
shattered a tooth.
Wow.
My friends are fake.
Awesome.
Really was in a car accident as a kid really getting hit in the mouth with a bat
and then your dad throws you into the fucking game.
Just keeps me in the game.
Throws you back at the game.
Sorry,
what was that kid that hit you in the face of the bat?
Did you stay friends with him?
I didn't know that dude.
I never heard from another team.
It was the other team.
Wow.
Did he say sorry?
No I didn't.
Why don't I maybe,
I'm sure his mom made him say something,
but I wasn't in a place to hear it.
Wow.
Oh my birthday.
And we had to go to the dentist like for the emergency,
like did you ever see that kid again after that?
I have no idea who he was.
I don't even know the kid.
Wow.
That's probably better.
That way you don't have like this one person in your mind that you have to seek
out and destroy and you're,
you know,
you Facebooking.
I'm seeing that he's happy.
You're like,
fuck,
I have fake teeth and you just want to get back at him for some shit that
happened when you were 11 people.
I like that man.
People fucking fester on things where it'd be way better if you didn't know.
You know in that case you're not going to go back and fuck this 11 year old up
who's now 43 I don't even have attachment to the,
I don't have attachment to the incident.
In a weird way.
I'm kind of emotionally detached.
Right?
Thinks I've set it so much.
Yeah.
I got 26 teeth knocked out with a baseball bat and then that everyone goes,
how did that happen?
And you just almost like that event becomes a bit,
a little bit like something like,
I'm sure when you tell people about being the world judo champ,
I'm just never world
making shit up.
Uh,
what,
what you need alcohol.
What were you,
you were like the car.
I won a bunch of taekwondo tournament,
but like I'm sure that somehow you definitely kind of like,
you hear a hum.
How flippantly you just said that?
Yeah.
I'm sure it was so long ago,
man.
It doesn't feel like me when I,
when I talk about it quite honestly,
it's so long ago.
It feels like a lie.
Yeah,
I know.
It's real because I can do that stuff still and I'll show people and I go,
Holy Shit.
I go,
yeah.
It's kind of weird.
Right?
I could just do that.
So I know it was real,
but it feels so long ago.
It feels like a lie.
Yeah.
And my brother,
he wants some of this.
Brian.
No good.
Here's your call.
This is going downhill or uphill when you're something crazy,
man.
They're uh,
did you hear about the mall of America?
He would happen.
There was a black lives matter protest if they shut down the mall of America
during the busiest time of the year,
you know,
thousands of people chanting and protesting.
Well,
um,
they're getting sued.
The people organize a protest or getting sued and they seek reparations from the
mall of America protest.
The mall is suing him for loss business,
which is significant.
You know,
like this is a very interesting man.
It's like these guys that are like protesting by going in the middle of the
freeway here in Los Angeles.
That pisses me off.
Yeah,
we talked about the other day because I think that you can't,
you gotta be real.
Oh,
you weren't here,
the Casper and one,
you gotta be careful because you could,
somebody could die.
Like there could be someone who's on their way to the hospital and you,
you block off the ambulance and because the hospital gets in there an hour later
than they should have,
the guy dies.
And that could be someone's loved ones.
That's fucked up.
That's just,
that's not cool.
It's and people like,
well you know it's a protest and protest or not supposed to be convenient.
There's one thing where it's convenient.
It's another thing where it's public safety.
You know,
you could all,
everyone who's involved in that essentially could be charged with murder.
Like if if you in some way cause someone's death because of negligence or
because of a malicious activity where they could,
couldn't decided malicious activity.
I bet it there could be an argument made.
I mean if you,
it was one person physically,
if you knew that there was an ambulance and you blocked it off cause you say no,
the ambulance can't get through because a black lives matter or whatever your
causes.
If you stop that ambulance from going somewhere,
you personally,
they would charge you for sure with something,
whether it would be murder or some negligent homicide or something.
I mean they would figure out,
I don't know what the costs would be.
So the question becomes when you have a whole group of people that are blocking
off the highway,
how many of those people responsible,
cause there's this weird thing that happens,
diffusion of responsibility when you get large numbers.
It's one of the reasons why a mob mentalities are so scary because no one feels
responsible when everything's going crazy and people just run around smashing
windows and like you gotta be really careful about people in that kind of shit
happens because when no one feels like there's any order and everyone feels like
this chaos,
people just start doing shit.
They start looting.
I mean that's where you get like these crazy mass rapes where everybody's like,
how is this possible?
Like you hear about them in India,
we're hundred guys rape woman and the woman dies.
Like how the fuck could this happen?
Well I think that people have a weird follow mentality then some weird ancient
primate shit that's in us where we follow other people.
Even when things get crazy and when things get completely off the rails.
Fucking crazy.
Like a riot.
I think it's almost like for whatever reason,
people,
a certain amount of them at least glues themselves in those moments and they
can,
they could stomp people to death too.
They could light things on fire to where they would never do that individually
on their own.
And I think,
um,
you have to wonder when you have a situation where a whole group of people do
it,
but that's not there.
I mean they,
they block off traffic but their intention is not to stop ambulances or to stop
police.
Their intention is just for good,
you know,
their intention is to try to put,
put the message out there in big letters as possible to let everybody know we're
going to inconvenience the fuck out of,
you know,
more highways like until there's some action,
until someone does something.
The problem is we need those goddamn roads.
That's something that you can't take that away that,
I mean,
you're right.
I never thought about what if someone's just on their way to the hospital as the
first thing I thought of because I had to take my daughter to hospital recently.
She broke her arm,
fell off the monkey bars and broke her arm.
So when,
when that kind of shit happens and you realize like time is of the essence and
you know my daughter's case,
it's a broken arm.
They know how to fix that stuff.
But in some people's cases it's like,
you know you have organ malfunction.
There's all sorts of things that happened to people's bodies that they can
catch.
They can catch in time,
you can stay alive.
But imagine how upset you'd be if you never get to talk to your dad again
because some fucking hipsters are blocking off the highway,
you know,
cause they want to show how down they weren't.
So they're blocking off the highway.
That's where I become a single shooter,
Mark Walberg well I know that what they're trying to do as good,
I know what they're trying to do is good.
But there there's a,
there's a reality to protesting where he got to go.
Okay,
but at what cost at the cost of your fellow citizens,
like these aren't cops you're talking about that you're inconveniencing or,
or possibly putting their lives in danger.
This is your neighbors.
This is your friend's.
Imagine a few words.
Your nextdoor neighbor major,
if you were a protester,
he next door neighbor's husband had a heart attack and they're trying to get him
to the hospital,
but they couldn't get into any time.
They were like,
if you just got him here half an hour earlier,
we'd have been fine,
but it was 90 minutes it took to get them to the hospital.
So the guy died and she's crying and crying and you're out there trying to say,
hey,
you know,
black lives matter.
It's important that you know,
we make it inconvenient and she's like,
you fuck my husband's dead now.
Everybody's lives matter.
Yeah.
It's just that's the only,
the only other than inconveniencing all the other fellow citizens which don't
have anything to do with police brutality,
it's like it seems like there should be,
there should be a way to do it where it doesn't put other people in jeopardy.
I don't know what that way is.
You know?
I would imagine that way is blocking off the front door to the police station or
blocking off even better the flow front,
front door to town hall.
That would be the best one.
Like if they were going to protest something and be heard and be,
you know,
be seen as they're getting arrested,
like some block block off where the laws are being made.
Don't block off the fucking highways,
be smart about it,
find your angle.
But I don't know man.
It's,
it's part of me likes that this is going on though,
you know,
pro.
Pardon me.
He's excited that there's all this talk.
They'll just like,
people are realizing there's some imbalance,
there's some issues,
you know,
and they're being addressed in like a really big way.
So I feel like it's ultimately a lot of good is coming out of all of this stuff.
A lot of good,
you know,
a lot of people are being forced to have these conversations and I've,
I've seen people adjust their,
their,
uh,
opinions during these conversations.
It's kind of interesting.
I think I've just adjusted my opinions throughout the entire thing.
Cause I,
you know,
I,
the only thing that this,
that,
that I guess arguably be arguably Fox News and CNN don't do,
is they don't offer a,
like a real fair and balanced kind of conversation with two intelligent people.
They,
they buttload it where they get like they get on,
they get,
they did this thing with Charles Barkley being in TV as long as I have,
I,
there are certain things I know don't fucking happen.
And they bring Charles Barkley,
the one guy that maybe can give a really interesting point of view and he starts
sweating in the interview.
Did you see it anywhere else in an interview on TV?
They would stop down and say,
you look a little shiny,
let's dry dry you off anywhere else.
But they allowed it to go and like this Nixon Kennedy debate kind of way and he
had sweat on top of his lip.
It was porn off side of his head as he was talking about something that is maybe
not,
uh,
the,
the high road or not the,
not the high road,
but like what the status quo is,
but CNN w or I think it was CNN wanted the drama of it.
They wanted his statements.
Do I have weight with this,
with this sweaty persona of like,
I'm fucking scared and the any in any interview,
and I'm sure this has happened to you,
they will stop you down and go stop.
No matter what.
He's a little shiny.
Let's try him off.
Like if you started sweating in,
in like a,
in like an interview about the UFC and it was just,
you were just talking,
right.
They definitely stop you down and go,
let's give him a little powder.
They don't,
I don't let them do that really.
But if you started sweating when you think they'd let you dry off or you have
say,
dude,
but yeah,
maybe that's a bad fucking,
I feel like such a pussy if I let them powder my forehead.
It has a bad fucking example.
Girls are getting their ears broken off.
You see that this girl got her ear ear was destroyed.
Jessica,
I and I've,
I forget the lady's name.
I'll find it here.
Oh,
it exploded.
It was insane.
Did you see a prion hall?
It was the fucking craziest Shit I've ever seen in all my years of watching.
Well,
one of the cray Leslie Smith,
she fought Leslie Smith who's tough as shit and cheat her ear.
Swole up and she had a,
you know,
cauliflower ear and what cauliflower ear is the reason why your ear gets hard is
your,
when you have bleeding under the skin,
the blood pools under the skin and then it calcifies it hardens up.
It becomes like a little piece hard.
Like I have some on my knuckle and I have a little bit on my ear.
It's real weird.
I wear ear guard so I don't get it on my ear.
But some people liked the way it looks,
so they don't wear ear guards.
They let it fucks with your hearing too.
I mean it makes you look like a bad ass I guess,
but it it,
it fucks with the way you hear things like your ears designed.
So that sound hits that,
that shape and like that's why women can't hear Shit,
dude.
They're ears are covered with hair.
They don't know what's going on.
They don't hear you when you're talking to them.
That's what's happening here.
I don't mean this,
these are jokes,
but this woman,
anyway,
Leslie Smith had a,
she had some series,
cauliflower ear and must've had some actual bleeding in the ear while the fight
was going on and then she got hit with this punch and it fucking explodes like a
jelly doughnut that got hit with a rifle.
I thought it ripped her ear off.
That's what it looked like.
It ripped a rear off and no,
it almost did that.
But it exploded first.
And as you can see it,
pull it up,
pull up,
pull up Leslie Smith,
exploding ear Gif because a,
it's crazy to say I've never seen anything like it.
She got Jessica hit her with his punch and as her knuckle connects with the ear,
the ear just explodes in a cartoonish spray of blood.
Like if it was in like one of those sin city,
those movies,
you know,
everything's very cartoony nations.
Yeah.
It didn't look real.
Like if it was in a movie.
Yeah,
it was in a movie.
You had to go get the fuck out of here.
I've never seen it.
You're blowup like that.
Watch this man.
It's,
it's so crazy.
Watch this.
It's low resolution.
Unfortunately.
You got to see it.
I'm not on these goofy screens where we have a new system that's in,
uh,
in order right now and the new system will be a tri caster.
We're going to use a tri county.
You can't really see it here.
Can you see it?
I can see it.
It's hard to see with this low resolution,
but in high resolution it looks fucking insane.
It's interesting that wrestlers and fighters,
they want the cauliflower flower ear.
Not all of them,
but uh,
they want the cauliflower ear.
I think I talked to Matt Brown about it.
I think my brown has got it.
And I said,
isn't that something you guys want to when you're younger?
And he was like,
fuck no.
But I guess some guys,
some guys do well I know people who have actually given it to themselves,
they've taken a belt and they fucked their ear up.
If you bend your ear and you just take a belt and fuck with it.
Yeah,
people liked the way it looks.
It makes you look like a Badass.
I've met guys who were fucking white belt to have this horrible cauliflower all
over their ears and a,
you're like,
come on man,
I've been doing Jujitsu for 20 years.
I don't have that shit.
How do you have that show so early?
Like how'd you get it so early?
And you know,
you find out that they did a lot of wrestling or they did a lot of,
uh,
you know,
horsing around with their friends and if you have the genetic predisposition to
getting cauliflower,
apparently it happened super easy.
Some people,
even though they've been doing Jujitsu for a long time,
like John Jacques Machado has so little of it,
but he's been doing Jujitsu his whole life and he doesn't wear rash cards.
Isn't there a way to,
isn't there a way to prevent it by draining it or something?
Once you got the,
you could drain it.
My,
yeah,
my friend Brent had his fixed,
he had um,
he had his ear filleted open and they scrape it all out and then stitch it back
together again.
He had it fixed and it looks weird.
The,
his ear looks like a little Collie flowery,
but not much.
But apparently it was pretty bad.
It was like,
like some of the wrestlers like Randy coture has like mice grown into year.
It's,
Randy's is so bad that I would,
I got to look at it like,
and it was like a pinhole.
This is your whole,
yeah,
it's really tiny.
Like he can't even get those apple ear buds are fucked.
Not Kidding.
He can't.
So w w why wouldn't he?
Because he's a bad ass.
He's fucking Randy coture once.
Let everybody know,
bitch,
I,
I'm again in the headlock since I was a baby.
So they said,
we don't want to fall asleep on planes also.
Well,
they're hard.
He uses him in wrestling.
Yeah,
he,
he holds onto you.
Like if he's got you and he's driving forward towards your face,
he'll like shoved that fucking ear and your eyeball.
It's hard.
So just kind of said it doesn't hurt him.
If it hurts him,
he doesn't care if it hurts you.
That's what he worked.
He's worried about if it hurts him slightly less and it hurts you slightly more,
he's going to do it.
That's what's,
that's what it's like.
You can't,
I can't,
I mean,
I'm around it all this time.
I'm good.
The exact opposite.
Exactly.
If it hurts you more or less than it hurts.
I don't want,
I'm fucking,
I could never be,
that
is the thing about wrestlers that a lot of people don't understand.
It's not just the fact that wrestling is a good base for martial arts,
for mixed martial arts.
I think it's the best because you could decide whether the fight goes to the
ground or the fight stands up and when you're really good grappler like Jujitsu
techniques,
you can learn all those and you can learn all those pretty quickly.
It's like the real deal is learning how to manipulate bodies and balance and
understanding,
positioning,
understanding like leverage and positioning and wrestlers get that.
But the real intense thing about wrestlers with separates them from other
athletes is the toughness like that.
You have to be so fucking tough to survive in a wrestling room.
There's the,
the drills are so brutal.
The sport itself,
like going at it like full clip with another guy who's also the same weight as
you.
Also just as strong as you.
It's one of the most difficult things in all sports.
So you could do to physically strong wrestlers with technique or just fucking
hammering it,
try and take each other.
John Sprawling,
trying to twist under each other,
trying to throw each other and you just constantly pushing each other to the
limit.
And if you can just get one mile an hour fast and this motherfucker,
you could break him.
Just make him go one mile an hour faster than he's comfortable with and keep
pushing and pushing and pushing.
So all the best wrestlers have this insane mental toughness is an innate or
trained,
trained 100%.
All of it is trained and people have a certain amount of determination,
but when,
one of the things you see when you see children is how children react to their
environment and stimulation and when it's something as extreme and as the
ability to endure pain and the ability to push themselves and it's prevalent all
throughout this one group of athletes,
you got to go,
well,
what's the practice?
It's what they're doing.
Like what are they doing?
They're making many of these fucking guys,
they're turning them into animals.
They're turning into people of extreme character like they can do things that it
doesn't mean other people can't do it.
There's,
there's guys that never wrestled who became mixed martial arts greats that also
have that same mantra like George Saint Pierre.
It's perfect.
Example became a great wrestler after he was already a UFC fighter.
It became one of the best wrestlers in MMA just by being a great martial artist.
But he had that mentality on his own and he didn't have to go to a wrestling
room his whole life to develop that.
He developed that from martial arts itself,
but you get a lot more of those in wrestling,
wrestling and get it.
You get a lot of them.
You get like one in every town,
every fucking wrestling team.
In My,
uh,
in my high school,
there was this kid mark calling and he was just,
he was a little bit lighter than me.
He's a really skinny guy.
He said smoke cigarettes in between breaks while we were wrestling or less
wrestling in the winter,
his girlfriend would meet him at the fucking side door,
the wrestling room,
and give him a cigarette.
He would take,
drag a cigarette and come in and wrestling,
beat everybody's ass and he smelled like cigarettes.
He's an animal.
He was an animal and he was a,
he was a couple of years older than me and he had been wrestling a good chunk of
his life and a on their,
forget this one day the coach,
uh,
like was as this guy was just smashing everybody,
the coach said,
pay attention to him because there's a guy like him and every fucking wrestling
room,
there's a guy like him on every wrestling team and he wasn't the biggest guy by
any stretch of the imagination,
but everybody was scared of him.
Everybody was scared of him.
Even the heavier wrestlers,
like he was like the captain of the team when he get mad at them for being a
pussy,
you know,
yell at them.
They'd just fucking bow their head down.
They just didn't want him,
nothing to do with this little fucking Tasmanian Devil.
He was just a whirlwind guy,
which is so aggressive.
And those guys,
there's like,
and he got beat.
He went to the fucking the states and he got beat.
I watched him lose.
The guys were even better than him.
I was like,
this is crazy.
This born like you,
you're going deep,
deep,
deep into the savage chain.
You're getting these fucking barbarians that are there.
Their DNA is so fucking good,
like their genetics are so good.
And then on top of that,
they're being trained to this really insane way where they're overtraining them
every day,
every day they're tired.
Everyday you're making exhausted kids run up hills and carry the kids on their
back and run.
Firemen carry drills.
You're doing fucking stairs with them.
You're carrying your friends where you're climbing up stairs,
doing all kinds of crazy shit.
You're walking on your hands back and forth across the fucking wrestling room.
You doing all these insane drills and you're going at it for hours a day in a
room.
That muscle likely has this best in it.
This is fucking pipes are covered in this.
I mean this is 1981 when I was wrestling and I need to,
and these pipes are all covered in this fucking spray,
serious foamy shit that's dropping out of the restroom.
You got to kick it off to the side like is this stuff safe?
Like we are going to have cancer when we're old.
But um,
first blowjob ever got was in a,
uh,
a wrestling room.
I know.
Make the dude take off.
Is here guards that your coach with a year,
God's help.
Do they help while dude sucking your Dick?
Yeah.
Good handle on it.
You don't
match.
If you took your check and you were like,
you put these on once you put the ear guards on why she said just need them.
I need them on you.
I mean with this thing lit up.
Yeah,
put this thing and on it make you check where a single,
put your titties outside this thing.
When I left one titty here went to the,
they're all crazy style.
I'm well past that.
That fed that role play.
What are you intellect?
Lumberjack shit.
Listen,
I'm,
I'm walking down the woods.
I'm a hiker and you're a lumber jacker and shit just gets crazy.
The only female lumber jacker the Yukon,
the guys left you behind and just been searching for that right guy.
Today's the day you just decided,
you woke up this morning.
Fucking,
I'm tired of being a virgin.
And then along comes Bert Kreischer the world traveler.
He's just a few minutes ahead of the trip flip team.
So he,
he's like,
I'm totally willing to fuck you,
but I'm doing this TV show for the child shall and there's a bunch of people
behind me and they're on vacation.
They're taking pictures.
That's why I'm a hand.
I'm supposed to scout ahead.
We can fuck,
but we gotta fuck really quick.
And this girl's first sexual experience.
Do you get to that deep level of a fantasy go so fucking funny.
That's an area where I've done,
not with wanting to fuck a chick,
but rolled up to a lumber jack who was a female with the triplet Google that
really did happen.
The hottest shit she was Holly shit,
it's so crazy that you even made that in my head.
I was like,
cause I,
first thing I thought was a lumberjack hand job from a check will be insane.
Wow.
Fucking just rough hands.
And then I thought I'd like that.
That'd be confusing.
I definitely didn't close my eyes.
I have to look cute.
You're definitely a chick,
right?
Hey,
no tricks.
No,
I wouldn't even,
not one eye.
Both eyes bro.
Looking right at them.
Very,
very intense.
Trusting someone holding on your balls and Dick like that.
The rough hands,
wood chips and their fingernails and stuff.
The scent of pine all over their clothes.
When we were up in Canada,
we pass by these,
um,
they have these uh,
cut breaks where there's like these areas that they cut all the trees down.
It's really weird man.
It's like,
cause you,
you go and you're driving down the road and you see like just beautiful trees
and it's amazing.
And then you'll hit this area.
Many football fields,
large just enormous area where it's all trees chopped down,
everything's chopped down and um,
some of it is piled up and then they have a few posts that they leave like out
there in the middle,
like trees
at elect cut in half and they leave out there in the middle.
And they do that for the birds.
They do that for the bird population because in order to,
it actually enhances the bird's ability to be a predator.
But like for Raptors,
hawks,
shit like that.
Eagles,
they have eagles up there for those animals.
They uh,
they want,
they need purchase in order to be able to look down and see all the different
rabbits and rats and all the different shit they're going to eat.
So if you make this huge cut,
break,
you cut down a bunch of trees and just leave nowhere where they can sit up.
They are only going to kill the things that are around the edges.
They're not going to see like a lot of the shit that's out there in the middle.
So they place these like posts to make it easier for these birds.
It's really weird.
It's very weird.
It's crazy that someone figured that out.
I think biologists get involved every step of the way when it comes to,
uh,
where you're allowed to cut,
what,
how much you're allowed to cut a,
what animal is going to be affected.
Like,
do you remember when they had that owl thing?
There was a thing about,
there was an owl problem.
Do remember that.
And they had to shut down,
um,
lumber that,
and it was somewhere in the Pacific northwest spotted owl.
Yeah.
There was a spotted owl issue where they were going extinct and so people were
freaking the fuck out because they couldn't make it make money.
Uh,
while this,
um,
this thing was going on,
here,
I'll put it down in lumber,
lumber shut down.
But uh,
that's like one of the things that people are terrified of when they're making
money off the environment.
They're terrified of all.
We found a frog,
a very rare frog within this one pond.
So you've got to stop drilling oil.
Why are you fucking crazy?
It's a frog.
We spend $1 billion to get this fucking machinery in here.
We need that oil.
And then you start greasing politicians.
Yeah.
The spotted owl,
they shut down,
uh,
the,
the Pacific northwest,
they shut down,
um,
timber production.
Really fucking fascinating story.
It is considering that's everyone's livelihood up there.
Not everyone,
but a vast majority of some people's livelihood.
Yeah.
Can consider the the popular,
uh,
the,
what's the guy that gets hired politician who was greenlit,
that must've known he was getting a shit storm coming his way.
I'm sure they probably get death threats.
Like if you come out and say you don't want them to make millions and millions
of dollars every week because of our fucking
bird to do two aren't really giving a fuck about birds.
Not to say don't give a fuck about burns.
If they gave a fuck about birds,
it wouldn't be chopping down trees had find a better job.
If you were in that because you were like super into birds,
that's the wrong job.
So in the wrong job,
wrong job
as your high school guidance counselor,
really
this guy is writing,
this guy's running a Sawyer,
a story.
William Dietrich,
I'm saying that he was trying to talk to the Seattle Times about this in 1988.
And uh,
they thought he was crazy.
They were laughing at him.
They were like,
this is this like this is a ridiculous notion.
You're telling us that a bird,
an obscure bird,
apparently it's not a very common bird that no one,
none of these people had ever seen would be enough to shut down the Pacific
northwest biggest industry and that's really what happened.
It's really interesting how that works,
man.
Really interesting how that works because I think there's,
there's a lot of people that get really upset about logging in the first place.
Let's do this.
Let's take that same subject and do what you did with the black lives matter
with the protest because arguably for this one bird says dad's going to lose his
job and he's not going to have the means to support his family the way he had
and may lose his house over a bird.
Is that worth it?
Well,
I don't think that we should want and Lee cause the extinction of an animal told
when an animal is a part of the ecosystem.
Do I think that ecosystem will survive?
Yes.
You know why?
Because I think that ecosystems are way more flexible than we want to think they
are.
I think they do adjust and survive,
but if we can prevent this animal from dying,
then we should definitely prevent this animal from going extinct.
I mean it just seems like if we're going to be,
you know,
humans like to be thought of as the caretakers of the earth or the curators of
the earth.
Let's start that with Americans.
Not Humans.
Yeah.
Americans.
We always,
you know,
when you look at our concern with global pandemics and global warming,
climate change,
all the different issues that people are very concerned about our role in
protecting the earth.
But if we're doing that and then we have some crazy fucking bird that's dying
off because we like to chop down trees like it seems like they should figure out
a way to save that bird.
It seems like this should be a way to get that bird and put them in an awesome
bird place just to let them fuck like crazy.
Go look dude,
we got all the fucking mice you ever want.
We're gonna like let Mike's out every day.
You fuck like crazy.
You make a bunch of out of the owls and we'll get your populations healthy and
let you go.
It seems like that would be like a good move.
Right?
Why not charge those lumber industries instead of shutting down everything?
Say Keep because they're going to go extinct.
I think they were worried that these things are going to go extinct.
Oh,
so,
so it's not just about money,
it's about this actual area is the only place birds still around?
Yeah,
it's like a really,
um,
that makes sense to me.
Yeah.
It's a really,
really obscure bird.
Apparently they're not in a lot of places,
but there's a lot of that area up there that's protected.
We went up there,
Duncan and I did to look for big foot when we do that.
So fast show stupid.
It was so silly.
But what sillies how beautiful that area is when you're up in Mount Rainier?
Dude,
it's crazy.
First of all,
it rains every day.
So the woods or just like the way I described it was like a box of Q tips like
this.
That's how many trees there are.
There were just trees upon trees upon trees and everything is so green and it
always looks kind of cool but it's always raining.
But then every now and then for like an hour or so,
the sun will break through the clouds.
When we were there,
we were there in May and it was uh,
still pretty remar march,
March one of those one m month where there during an m a month.
And um,
one time during the day the sun broke free for like a couple of hours and I was
like,
this is the most beautiful place on earth.
This is the most like sun was like beams of Sun.
We're cutting through the trees and everything was soaked and do and we were
standing next to a river which had like empty beer cans and shotgun shells all
over the fucking sure like Buckler,
Conte the owls.
But other than that,
the view is magnificent.
Like you're looking at such lush,
lush greenery.
There's something about that man that like,
it does something to your brain,
like it puts you on a frequency,
like quiet,
calm down bitch.
It just does some click.
It locks into,
there's something about your visual,
like the your visual field.
You take in this insane,
beautiful natural imagery of nature and that it has an effect on the mind and
you sit there and you're like,
that is,
I've been obsessed with this theory.
I went to this place called earned slow burn in New Zealand glacier.
They shot it in the hobbit is the waterfall.
That photo walks behind and we went into the waterfall,
swim,
the waterfall.
It's,
it's drip off from the glacier.
It was 32 degrees eight seconds ago.
Wow.
And I got there and I was obsessed.
And you know,
we talked about this on the phone like a month ago about when you're in comedy
brain,
you're almost like less happy because you can't,
you're obsessing about like when you're writing you're just kind of,
your brain's fucking on it won't shut down.
Right.
I was obsessed with the fact that like visually when I was a kid and I saw a
vagina for the first time,
it might be Barry's house.
I got turned on and I couldn't stop that feeling.
I got,
I got sexually turned on and I couldn't shut that down and I couldn't get my
brain to shut off.
But that,
look at this place earned slow burn.
I kept looking at it going,
it's as inspiring as the first Regina ever saw.
But what is,
what,
why is it that this has this reaction on me where I tear up and I go,
this is beautiful.
As opposed to getting turned on sexually.
Do you know,
do you know what I mean?
It's visual.
It's the exact same medium.
Yeah.
You talking about it,
it brings the opposite.
Almost like the,
the,
all the shit that sexuality does where it shuts your brain down and you just
want to fuck dick gets hard.
It does the opposite where it goes,
I have one.
I wish my kids were here.
I wish my wife was here.
Um,
I hope,
I hope my parents are proud,
like all these weird fucking,
but I just,
I was a,
I've been obsessed with that because there,
there are those things in life and I feel like I've,
I've been really lucky to experience them in the past six months in,
in,
in spades.
But like those moments where you take visual snapshots and you're like,
oh fuck.
Like when you're by that stream and,
and everything's,
and it stops raining and the sun peaks through and it hits that right moment,
you're like,
oh shit,
I'll never forget this moment.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I think,
um,
there's a reason why people go to art galleries,
you know,
like,
why do you go to our gallery?
He go there to see what people are capable of creating.
Like there's,
Oh,
it's always inspiring.
Like even like those tattoos we were looking at yesterday,
like,
wow,
somebody did that.
That one,
the Cheshire cat and that chick's ribs.
Like,
whoa,
that's crazy.
Right?
Like I like knowing that someone made us a cool sand castle.
Right.
There's something to that.
But then there's also something about just beauty.
There's something about beauty and beauty.
I think especially in our culture today,
it gets co opted by sexual attraction,
you know,
like be like a beautiful woman's body.
Like even if for whatever reason you decided you were never going to have sex
for the rest of your life and you were never attracted to a woman again,
you were fine with that for whatever reason.
Like you got hit by lightening and your Dick stop working.
He really didn't care anymore.
You were fine with it.
Like a John Travolta movie.
Out of that,
you saw like a perfect,
beautiful female body with curves and legs and breasts and bone structure and
just femininity.
It's beautiful.
Like a woman's body of a woman who is exercising as a healthy,
vibrant body.
It's an amazing thing to behold.
It's,
it's a,
Oh,
it's a work of beauty and there's something about it,
not just a sexual attraction to it,
but just the actual shape of it.
The curves,
like you know,
like that stupid Kim Kardashian breaks the Internet thing.
Like when you looked at that,
you're like,
wow,
that's crazy.
Her ass is ridiculous.
But what's,
what's doesn't work is that she's like,
look at me,
luck.
I'm an oil up my ass.
So you luck his rubber in my ass.
Don't tell anyone.
Shh.
Like why is your ass so big?
It wasn't that big at one point in time.
Do you just do a lot of squats
sorta.
It looks like she has a fucking diaper on right?
Sort of like she's got a rubber ass.
This is rubber in there.
Some sort of foreign.
But what doing is by seeing it in this beautiful form and shape,
it's like a sculpture.
There's like something to it,
you know like you're,
you're seeing is,
it's exaggerated and it's,
in her case,
this is not the best case,
but there's been some like insanely beautiful black and white photos of like,
like models on the beach.
You know where you look at these photos and you're like well that's just the
shape of the woman's body is like something.
And then you see like the shape of a mountain,
a snow capped mountain with beautiful green trees around it and the sun is like
passing through the cheese.
And you're like,
fuck,
that's amazing to look at.
There's something that happens to us when we see beauty
and when nature compliments beauty.
Like you said,
I believe this,
when the sun peaks through the nature of nature kind of just takes it to the
next level and he's like,
he's like,
take this all over your face,
nature of a woman.
It's like squirting.
She's squirting all over the universe that she created.
It's,
it's one of those moments like I woke up in this cave in Vietnam and the sun
came.
How many people are going to say that shined into the cave and say living
people,
I know,
I know.
but it's like those moments when nature and beauty and all show up at the same
time and you're like,
oh,
it's like they're talking to me,
you know?
Yeah,
yeah.
It's like it's giving you a message.
It's giving you a message.
Like,
behold,
all that I have in sign of me,
behold the clear water and the fucking bird,
the Chirp in my trees that sit on my mountain then and then when you're doing
your couple of music into it.
Oh yeah.
And in mushrooms.
Right.
And if you got alcohol,
you've got to Hud,
Ibrance,
nature,
beauty,
music.
Yeah.
Like I happen to me on airplanes when you just,
when you're the only one awake,
but you open up and the sun's rising over Tokyo and you're like,
and you got fucking something shitty song,
but it doesn't matter cause it just means the right thing to you.
And you're like,
fuck it.
Fuck it.
It's not that.
Hey,
now you're an all star.
Get you came on and you're like,
that's my fucking,
exactly.
Exactly.
Katy Perry's not Katy Perry.
Fucking um,
uh,
the girl with the,
it feels like a perfect night to dress up like hit or hip flares.
What fucking Hitler?
Jesus Christ.
Bert Kreischer
uh,
come on.
If the girl that won the fucking Emmy and won the grammy and then it's the one
where everyone's telling me like,
I hate to admit it.
I love this new albums and Katy Perry,
Taylor swift.
Taylor swift is a fucking awesome dude.
If you want to get,
especially hold on.
No,
let me tell you something Joe.
I swear to God,
I swear to God and think about what you're saying.
Your daughter,
your daughters,
and in two years we'll,
we'll change your playlist because you'll hear songs that remind you of them.
Sure.
It happens.
So don't know me
so wrong.
I have videos.
My daughter's singing that and I think it's awesome,
but when I'm in my fucking manly American car,
I don't listen to that horse shit.
What about like now you got,
hold on,
I'm on an airplane.
Dead Lifts and I'm listening to Zeplin fuck off.
I'm on an airplane,
I'm having a few cocktails.
It's a long flight.
It's an unusual day
and
that song and you be honest,
you listen to that song a little under listen,
it's on my,
on my phone because my girl take my phone might be dead honest with two
daughters.
You've got a younger and that song.
Do you build a snow man?
Cause you just think like what if my younger daughter come and I start bawling?
Just sobbing.
I definitely get
when I see things that they like and I'm not around them,
but that's why I don't,
I don't stay away for long.
It's like you go away for like these big long stretches.
I don't go away for very long the longest ago ways when I go hunting,
like UFC trips and calming trips is a couple of days at most.
So I don't like going away,
man,
I don't like it.
I don't like that feeling.
It's like when I was a kid,
I didn't have a lot of stability in my life and I think almost none of my
friends did,
which is weird because it's like,
it makes interesting people.
I don't want my kids to be interesting
to be fucking boring as shit and happy and content.
But that's selfish,
right?
I mean it's like I think,
uh,
I will expose them to difficult scenarios in life,
but I want to build a base of love and support first because I recognize
there's,
there's a bunch,
there's a bunch of variables involved in making human being and I think you
probably thought about this as well.
When you think about raising a kid,
you don't,
you don't just a feed them and you know just sort of read books to them before
you go to bed with them.
You have to explain to them life,
you're teaching them about things and you're setting examples and in a lot of
ways it's a huge fucking responsibility like that a lot of people don't really
consider,
you sort of think that your kids are going to figure it out on their own and
they will if you don't help them,
but you're really supposed to be there to fucking help them.
Just like every other animal like cats.
They'll like hold onto a mouse and they'll drop it near the kit and so the kit
and we'll chase the mouse and hold on to it.
They're like,
teach this kitten had a Honda mouse by bringing them a half dead mouse.
Like cats go and Jack a mouse,
which picking barely jack them just hold on one and they drop them off in front
of their kittens.
I've seen him do it.
It's weird.
It's weird to watch,
but they're teaching,
they're teaching them.
Some people don't teach their kids Jack Shit.
You know,
and I think the best teacher in life is adversity.
The thing is how much adversity you want to give your kids cause you give them
too much and fucks him up.
If you give them not enough,
they become spoiled.
It's like you have to figure out,
they need to learn to overcome obstacles and it's just like everything else in
life.
You start with a little obstacle and that obstacle,
like how do you get to become a really good comic?
Bert Kreischer you start off at open mic nights.
That's their first obstacle.
Hit on by other comics.
So you've and you need your heartbroken and your ego's stomped on and you do
realize how bad you are and need to be objective.
You need to come to terms with that.
When you're the back of a taxi with your sister and she came up to see you
perform in New York and you're sitting there and you're all your things.
And my sister was so embarrassed to be with me,
she pulled off that New York taxi cab mask to not look at me.
Oh No.
And that you're here.
You want to get worse.
She put it on my good tar.
That's how bad I did guitar.
I did.
I tried to,
it was the first time I tried to do music and we're talking 1998 and I,
and she put it all my guitar.
It's still on my guitar case.
Every time I look at that map,
I think my sister could not make eye contact with me cause,
but you need that.
And,
and now here's a question.
How much do you,
how much do you swing that poll?
Because all the old,
ultimately you want your daughters to have some of the same brilliant
experiences you've had in your life where you sit there and,
and not just,
you know,
cage side at a UFC,
their equivalent of that.
But like you want them to also feel like they've earned it.
Right.
You know,
that's the one thing that I'm so grateful about is that,
you know,
I earned standup comedy.
You know,
like I didn't know I wasn't gifted to me.
I earned,
I had to work for it and that wasn't my place in life.
I wasn't a kid that got that earned anything.
I never read books.
I was just a kid who fucking floated by until I got into comedy.
And I saw,
and I remember seeing guys like Jim Norton going,
Oh shit.
Like he's earned,
like he's working for this and Bobby Kelly and Pete Ollie,
these guys were all guys that I was looking at working for it.
And I,
and I did,
I wanted a shortcut so bad cause that was what life had been.
But I looked at them and I was like,
fuck,
I got to work it.
I didn't understand that until I worked at door to get on stage.
And you were like 10 steps below what they had ever seen because no one did
that.
New York,
you work the door,
Boston comedy club.
And so what year is it?
Nineties eight 90
so I was already gone.
I wasn't,
I didn't come back there while you were working there.
How?
No,
no,
but,
but even still like,
you know I had,
you know Jim,
I see Jim,
I see Jim in New York.
Chris had him on my podcast.
It's nice to know he's,
I think he's a genius comic,
but we're,
we're peers in the same business.
Talk about all that.
But to a fucking earned it.
Like I want my kids to earn shit.
Yeah.
I don't know how to do that because you can listen.
You can only lead by example in certain respects.
But what you're saying is true.
Like one of the things that's weird about being a fuck up in life or being a
funny person is what you,
the skill that you developed that people don't think of as marketable or don't
think of as valuable as you became a very socially viable person.
You even though you didn't do well in school,
you were concentrating on other things and one of those other things you were
concentrating on is a bit in a big way is being amusing to people.
Getting people to like you being what your book is called,
the life of the fucking party.
I mean that's what you work but people don't think of that as being a skill but
of course it's a skill you figured out through a lot of trial and error through
years of of adjustment,
years of of life interacting with people and realizing what people like.
Then once you find it,
tapping into it and running with it and then using alcohol to fuel it to take
away your ambitions and run with it.
You're developing a martial art,
the martial art of comedy.
I mean it's really in a,
in a way there are analogies to developing a Marshall like becoming like a
martial artist because one of the things about becoming a martial artist is you
find the tools that work.
You're taught it more than you are with comedy.
Comedy,
everybody's different.
Like with martial arts,
you have your basics,
you have your striking basics,
you have your grappling basics.
Someone teaches it and then you express yourself and you figure out how,
what you're doing,
what works,
what doesn't work and you get coached along the way.
Comedy,
you have to coach yourself.
But in a lot of ways it's similar in that,
and I don't mean it in a macho sense,
I'm similar.
It's similar in almost like this objective analogous way where you're looking at
comedy like a puzzle.
Whereas martial artists kind of like a puzzle to like when you,
when you were competing with a person,
even when you're doing just,
uh,
you know,
judo or something like that,
we're just trying to throw them to the ground there.
A puzzle.
How,
what do I have need to do to get this person on their back?
What do I need to do to get these people to laugh?
What do I need to do?
Do I need to do I need,
do I need to fucking drink more?
Do I need to be the guy who always takes his shirt off?
Do I need to be the guy who was in his underwear?
We're going in the water.
Fucking,
I don't care if it's winter,
we're going to the fucking water parts in the water.
He's said the maniac.
We love him and people love you because of that.
And then you run with that and then all of a sudden you're on stage and you've
got 300 people laughing their fucking dicks and tits off and they're going,
this guy is awesome.
We can't wait to see you again.
And then your parents like,
hold on.
So all that shit you were doing where I thought you were a fuckup,
you were actually developing a skill.
This skill that Bert Kreischer developed where everybody thought he was fucking
up was,
everybody loves Bert.
Fuck Raymond.
Everybody loves the bird.
I Love Ray to Ray Romano is a great guy.
I'm just saying people love you.
Like if you had,
everybody loves Bert,
even Ray Romano,
we'll probably go,
yeah,
I guess you could use it.
He wouldn't freak out if you try to do a sitcom called everybody loves Bert.
Everybody does love birds.
It doesn't take away from everybody loves Raymond.
It should be a goddamn franchise.
Some people love red band.
That would be the next one.
Some people think a Douche.
That's the next one and it would be me be going,
me going,
sorry.
I know I come some time to come off.
That's what you were doing when you were becoming this very social creature.
I was.
I was a very unsocial person.
I had to figure out comedy from a different angle,
you know?
And as I,
I sorta got better and slowly better.
And Kalia also relaxed as a person and as I relaxed as a person,
I got better as a comedian.
As I became a friendlier person,
Like all those things played a part in each other.
Like in the beginning,
I think a lot of what I was doing,
I was like battling against myself.
I was the opposite of you.
Instead of being like a very gregarious,
outgoing and really fun to be around guy,
I was kind of crazy.
I was dealing with the fact that I had a weird childhood and it was spent a
large percentage of my young teenage years in terror competing in martial arts
tournaments always being scared.
So my approach to it was like I had to develop the other,
I had to learn how to relax.
Like it took me awhile to learn how to relax.
And one of the best ways you learn how to relax is to see other people's
reaction to you.
You know,
and you bomb or you know,
you just,
you come off obnoxious and you realize as you're coming off of noxious God,
I'm of noxious.
Like what is wrong with me?
It's just the words come out of your mouth,
you know?
And as I've become a father,
especially as I've gotten older as well,
but as it become a father because I get to see it from the source.
One of the really unique things about becoming a father,
and I'm sure you would probably agree with this,
is you get to see a child from the source like right out of the box.
And you get to see them grow and develop.
And it is so fascinating.
Like when my daughter makes me laugh,
there's a weirdness to that laughter that I can't describe.
You know,
like my,
uh,
my six year old's really funny and she gives me a hard time.
Like she's always mocking me and making fun of me,
constantly mocking me constantly.
And it's so funny.
It's hilarious.
It's,
it's really like,
she like has this like almost like painful grin on her face.
Like she loves fucking with me and she loves it also because I can't stop
laughing when she does it because this is weird thing is this little human that
I've watched learn how to talk and then start fucking with me and figure you out
short,
tiny quick.
But I also tell her what I do wrong.
I tell her where I screw up and I tell one of the things that I do with my kids.
It's a,
it's a big one,
man.
I think everybody should do it.
Whenever I correct my kid about anything,
if she doesn't tell the truth about something or if she gets upset about
something,
I say,
honey,
I did the exact same thing.
I was way worse than you though.
I was way worse than you and I always tell them I was not as smart as you.
You're smarter than me and I explain.
I go,
this is where you're going to learn along the way.
So you're already give them a victory.
Like,
okay,
dad was worse than me and I'm smarter than Dad.
Okay,
keep talking.
What else?
Listening in,
I also,
I keep drilling in their head.
This is a big one that I drilled in their head.
The only difference she knew in me is that I've been alive longer.
I'm not better than you.
Okay?
I'm just a person who's lived more years,
but I can shave years off of your learning process if you just listen to me
cause I'll never lie to you.
I'm like,
if I'm telling you something except for Santa Claus,
if I'm telling you something got a big issue,
I've got a whole bit about it.
The wife doesn't know about,
well you know you're not lying to these little fucking kids.
She was in,
we were in the car the other day.
She was asking about the tooth fair.
She doesn't believe in the tooth fairy.
She's like,
that seems like bullshit that's trickled down.
Loss
of faith economics.
But the problem is the four year old man,
the four year old believes in everything and she's going to miss out on a couple
of years of being lied to.
Oh my 10 year old's still believe
no,
10 years old.
He needed to bring their kid to a doctor.
Dude,
I was taking shit to the next level.
My uncle Pete,
I wasco.
Nope.
My uncle Pete,
I saved in my phone as Santa Claus.
That's fuck outta here.
Joe Santa Claus calling you Joe Joe.
No,
I get no,
I'm taking,
I like,
I look,
hang on.
Take a look at this.
I saved,
let's type in Santa.
I saved his fucking picture.
So when he calls me,
Oh my God,
the phone rings and you see Sanas face and it's uncle Pete and he's got a few
Budweisers in him at midnight on Christmas Eve and he just like,
oh yeah.
The problem is that's trickled down economics when you tell your kid to make
sure her boyfriend wears a condom.
Okay.
She's going to of years from now.
Okay,
honey,
look,
I know Mike is your boyfriend and now you love each other and you gonna to be
together forever.
Wherever I'm going,
I'm okay.
Do you know make them wear a condom?
Make more con for Daddy.
Make a mark condom.
No,
dude wants to wear a condom.
I wore a condom at least five times in my life.
Really?
Five times,
maybe 10.
I've got a handful on me.
What are you trying to say?
Let's shut this podcast down.
[inaudible] hard.
Don't put me in the song and make me fuck my way out.
Never those fight companions.
I don't even need to see anything.
It's right there.
This is how good the Internet is.
Bam.
He says that,
and it's right there at my computer is one.
It's the hardest I've ever laughed people because I thought the flight,
if I companion,
I was like,
I'm probably not going to get as into it as I do the podcast because I've lost
it on the podcast.
I can't listen to it in bed anymore.
You're going to sleep.
So I was like,
I'll put in the fight companion.
I don't know.
It did.
It must have been like three weeks ago.
Oh,
you mean the one where I talked to him about his fight?
No,
no,
no.
What the fuck my way that was actually,
you were a little bit more than that.
You were so loose with Eddie and him and it was such a fucking fun atmosphere
that I sat up in bed and I was like,
fuck it.
That was the Ian Edwards or um,
uh,
Ian McCaw as well was here,
right?
Yeah.
Was He,
it was small brain.
I know it was Eddie,
you and Brendan.
Cause Fuck my way out of a sauna was my funniest thing.
I've heard it like I wrote it down on my head and I was like,
I got to bring that up.
It was about a guy w Eddie and I used to work at a 24 hour fitness and there was
a guy who was a manager there that was a really friendly guy that was also
before he was manager there in the West hills location.
He was a manager of the one in West Hollywood and the West Hollywood one was
just basically like a pit stop for dudes.
Just get to dex drain.
I worked out at West Hollywood crunch.
That was a fucking meat law.
That's a crazy spot.
Twos.
We'd just be sitting there shaving their balls.
I worked
out in,
I had a whole bit,
I did never made it onto a DVD or a CD or anything.
It was a whole bit about working out at Gold's gym on Cole Street in West
Hollywood because news radio was in this one area and Gold's gym was right down
the street.
I was like,
oh,
that's convenient.
I'll just work out there.
I worked out there twice.
I spent,
I've spent whatever.
It was like,
I think you had to get like three months.
I was like,
yeah,
I don't,
I'm not comfortable man,
and then I understood what it's like to be a woman.
I really did.
I understand what it's like to be a woman.
She's a woman with a skirt on and an office full of fucking savages just walking
past that water cooler while they're all quiet holding onto the little paper
cup.
Just the problem is I like it like you,
like what were the women did antelope or you're like being the dude.
Know that by the water cooler.
Being a sexual harasser,
I never had a problem with dudes like hitting on me.
I was always like,
that's what,
that's what I got it.
Guess what?
That's a new meme.
I never had a problem with dudes hitting on me cause I was like guess what?
Guess what?
I got it.
Somebody's going to try to fuck you now just to make a point.
I can't get the visual of guys who hate owls out of my head and that was the
fucking greatest analogy and all I can pitch,
you know there's people that sit outside Gelson's and try to get you to sign
forms about,
they're like catch you in the like,
hey do you wanna stand up for gays and your like with your kid and you're like I
do.
But right now I've got groceries and a child and I can't make a political
statement.
I don't know how much that helps a god put his finger in front of my face and
said,
do you have two minutes for gay rights?
And then my,
c'mon man,
what do you,
what do you mean this is not,
this is not the way to get people to like you.
You can't trap them when they're on the way to doing other stuff and like make
them sign pieces of paper the way we get.
Yeah.
This is the way we get,
you know,
signatures for our petition,
another way,
make a website.
Okay,
get,
you'll get more than just standing in front of a fucking doorway.
What are the numbers like as far as like annoying people for knowing people
slash you know,
get,
get people to sign your petition.
You're going to annoy way more people.
If you get people to do it on a website through social media,
you don't tweet me,
I'll retweet it.
Only hit at 1.4 million people.
That's way better than annoying me when I'm coming.
Obviously I'm an unusual case,
but most people,
what are the numbers of people that come out of whole foods?
Is it a hundred and hour?
Is it even a hundred the attrition factor of like you're just bothering people
and put flipping on the other side of it as opposed to it really fucking
helping.
I know a dude who won't go to a fucking super,
he'll pull a new supermarket and if he sees there's people that have like the
stand there and the the open bin for homeless people,
like what's up with that open fucking plastic thing with like this really easy
to unscrew tie.
You can just reach in and take that.
How do I know what the
fuck this is?
Money's going.
You have a laminated sign that says it's going to homeless people.
Those people are actually are fake.
Like I ignore them.
I don't even talk to them.
If they say something,
act like they don't exist.
Well I tried to be charitable except when forced,
whenever I'm forced or were cornered to be charitable.
I'm not charitable.
I'm very charitable.
If if it's much choice,
I like to give money but I don't like to be asked to give money I think.
I think that's obnoxious.
I think making someone aware of your,
your charity is cool,
but you got to leave it at that.
Like getting in front of someone,
putting a finger.
Do you have three minutes for gay rights?
Like,
that's on how it works,
man.
This is what I have for gay rights.
All the love in the world.
Okay,
I got all the love in the world.
You're not,
you don't have to worry about me because when it comes time to voting and it
comes time to talking about it,
I'm,
I'm not your enemy at all.
I'm 100% for you,
so don't worry about me.
You and Todd glass with the reason I don't say the f word.
I used to say faggot.
I loved it.
I know.
But you had talked about,
you know,
they've kind of taken it from us.
No,
no,
no.
Can I tell you what I believe Dave,
Dave,
what they've done is they've let it age like a fine wine.
So now when you do hear it,
it comes out like a bomb,
like a bomb.
And it's even 10 times funnier than it ever was when we were kids.
Well,
amongst friends,
if Brian,
if you were,
if you said something and Brian just goes,
shut up,
faggot starts would start crying if you just nailed it.
If you just had that one moment like a Mary Lou,
right?
Yeah.
Well you were talking about how you're scared to get your feet wet or something
like that if he says stuff like that.
But if there was a Gig,
but if Justin Martin Dale was sitting right beside you,
if Justin Martin Dale,
who we love dearly,
it was sitting right beside you and be like,
oh fuck.
Um,
I gotta say this.
I got to say this because I'm never going to fucking remember this.
And the whole time you were saying this house,
I felt bad.
There was one guy at the Gelson's on Riverside and Little Canyon for gay rights.
And as I walked out and he went boom machine and I went,
hey,
and he goes,
Yo,
gay rights.
And I was just went,
Nah.
And he was like,
oh,
got it.
And just walked off bat.
I can give you 20 bucks you need to stop talking to immediately.
Amen.
Can I just give you 20 bucks and we end this talk
to you about the weather?
Just don't ask me.
I just,
I find it obnoxious when I don't,
and it's like anything,
I can't out flyers for a show to people that are coming out of the bathroom.
No,
you don't do that.
They don't,
that's not what they're looking for.
You know?
I believe that you can,
you can get results from annoying people,
but you're also going to annoy people and whenever you can not annoy people,
that's the way to go.
Like if there's a way to do it.
Like I always feel like I don't,
I don't like advertising shit.
Like I don't like advertising sponsors.
I don't like advertising shows.
But the only way to let people know about those shows is to advertise them.
It's the only way,
but there's like a fine line between too much and too little and not enough.
And what's your intention?
Why you're going into it?
And I always feel like if someone's on my Twitter,
you know,
I'm going to talk about shows,
I'm going to talk about UFC.
UFC is coming up,
I'm going to let you know.
I mean,
but it's also because I'm fucking actually legitimately excited about it.
You know,
if I'm doing a show in New Year's Eve,
I'm excited about that show.
If I'm going to a UFC and I'm telling you,
Whoa Shit,
Jon Jones is fighting Daniel Cormier.
Me,
I'm not,
um,
uh,
yeah,
my letting you know you should order an on paper view,
but I'm not trying to do it for like job security.
I'm trying to do it because I fucking love it and I want everybody know about
it.
Yeah.
So as long as my heart is pure,
I'm willing to go forward with these ideas.
Speaking of boys in New Year's Eve,
I'll be at the Irvine improv where you Holla the Improv on Hollywood,
Melrose in Hollywood.
Yeah.
With Ian Edwards and Tony Hinchcliffe.
Jesus fucking Christ.
In other words,
it's true.
It's funny,
motherfucker.
Ian Edwards is the most underrated comedian in America today.
I'm telling you folks,
if you have a chance to see this guy,
I just don't say it enough.
There are some great,
great,
great comedians out there.
Ian Edwards is up there with all of them.
He's up there with bill burr.
He's up there with Dave Chappelle.
He's up there with Louis C K who's a mix up there with Brian Redman.
He's up there with Bert Kreischer,
Thompson Guerra.
He's fucking fantastic.
Good as Joey is.
I don't like saying that cause Joey makes me laugh harder than anybody that's
ever lived.
Ian Edwards is a motherfucker,
dude.
I,
I worked with him in Philly and DC and it was a pleasure.
It was a pleasure.
I was like,
how do more,
he's like one of those dudes where you feel like God damn people who need to
know about him because he's so good.
He's so good.
And he's got this rhythm where he Bailey's putting out any energy and she's
just,
people were falling down crying.
It sounds like it's a forced rhythm.
Like not,
not say that Mitch Hedberg was,
but it's,
it's so genuine way that he talks when he was talking about,
I think he was on the show when he's talking about he was gonna move out.
He had to move out of his house,
put stuff into a,
into a storage unit and then the place didn't go into escrow and,
and but the way he talked about tragedy was the same way he did comedy.
He goes,
I've got money,
but I'm not going to do it cause it's not going to sound right.
But I thought to myself,
and he used to work at the Boston Comedy Club.
He was one of the regulars there when I worked the door.
And you just sit in the back with a long ass dreadlocks.
I wrote a joke about him because his hair was falling out,
but he didn't,
I didn't even know I wrote it,
but I said,
when you're a have dreadlocks in,
your hair's falling out.
Do you just lose just one dreadlock at the time you wake up with a snake in your
pillow and yet
he didn't know he,
it's like hanging rope that's been halfway severed in an action movie.
When you see those strands breaking,
this spiraling,
I just bumped this camera.
Don't worry about it.
But yeah,
in Edwards is fucking,
he's amazing dude too,
man.
He's a really,
really,
really good dude.
Can I tell,
can I tell you what,
if I could talk to him,
what I'd want to talk about.
There was a sex,
there was a time,
no,
there was a time that everyone in New York talked about like Patrice,
everyone that we're Hemi Chappelle went to Edinborough together and apparently
they day they had this epic.
I mean it could have been just one of those folklore things that one joke turns
into 10 turns into 20 turns into make believe.
But man,
apparently they're like Hemi Chappelle and Jason Steinburge and Barry Katz all
went to Edinborough together,
like back in like fucking 92 or 95 I would love to,
if anyone ever gets the most podcasts,
bring them up because I'm dying to hear the stories.
And what happened?
I don't know.
There was this story about same.
I'll let him tell it.
Brave heart stopped.
It was written on animal skins on a snowy marsh.
Ah,
someone with a feather
dipped it into ink that was made from coal.
I scroll these words,
Ian Edwards and Dave Chappelle.
I don't know what happened was some shit went down or something.
Maybe Barry Katz was involved.
It's very shady.
Apparently.
It was hilarious.
It was like two dudes who are different people and they were just like,
it was like the odd couple.
I don't know.
Ian Edwards in Dave Chappelle.
There are the odd couple of very different people I guess.
Well,
Ian is a v He's a Vegan.
Yeah.
He's very healthy.
I couldn't do healthy clearly.
Yup.
Whiskey.
Are we done with it or we know speaking in front of your bitch.
Maker's mark ice in the metal thing.
That looks like a
tongs.
That's for gentlemen,
sir.
This is a gentleman's podcast.
We are in fact on iTunes.
I don't know if you know this with your dainty gold watch.
What's up with that watch?
Did you win that shit with one of those school cranes at the fucking carnival?
I almost didn't wear it today because I was like,
Joe fucking notice as fucking what's this strange watch?
It's also has you have a club wristband on seventies no,
it's a,
it's from the hospital.
Hospitals can't tell you something.
I was scared to sh AH,
fuck it.
I'm like,
if you're scared of what?
Nothing.
Nothing to show somebody why that myself.
Sometimes what happens around you is I get so fucking open that I do that bad.
I get scared.
You get scared because he get it open.
You have one drink and you're hammered.
You drink that whole bottle of champagne first.
Yeah.
Oh,
I didn't see that
before.
He got to celebrated way.
That's how you know someone's an alcoholic.
Not a word.
Not a word of what anybody likes.
Some champagne.
Open up a bottle of champagne.
He didn't offer any day anyone.
No one has had any of the champagne bar open.
That tit twisted a thing.
Pop the cork.
Oh,
so
first grade,
you don't know that we have a lot of liquor here.
You don't need to bring your own.
[inaudible] was so panicked and he was going to do this show sober.
He popped the cork and didn't tell anyone.
You didn't bring it up.
He didn't even talking,
but it's like you shot up in front of us.
You like fucking tied off with a rubber band.
Put it in your teeth,
you just fucking bang.
And we're just like
trying to pretend that it's not even happening.
I'm coming in hot.
I told you that.
That's not hot.
You came and got to open it.
You got to fucking Cork in front of you.
This is coming in rude
and selfish.
You'd come in in rude
dude.
I got to tell you,
I watched one of your videos of your,
um,
your podcast and I'm jealous of your man cave.
You know what?
I'm jealous.
I'm ready for this.
The wood on your walls.
What's that?
It's a,
it's a reclaimed lumber from,
I think 150 year old barn in Indiana.
Uh,
Noah,
you fuck it smells so good.
You walk into that man came in and smells like history.
I bet it does.
So it's son of a bitch.
I love old wood dude.
This fucking shit right here.
This is a hundred year old wood from a farmhouse.
I went way out of my way to get this would like reclaimed lumber.
I just had this idea that if I got old wood,
it would make me feel different when I was holding onto it and when I was
touching it,
it might be total horseshit.
But this wood right here,
that's what,
that's the man cave.
Let me see your band came to Joe.
See this,
know the difference between you and me.
What I make my own antlers.
Motherfucker.
Just see this.
See this map right here.
It goes up and there's an LCD screen behind it.
So it's like a secret TV.
Does Moose,
Bert Kreischer oh fuck.
What are you doing after you get out of here and he wants a moose?
I would absolutely loves him.
Um,
my uncle,
like right before the rolling stone magazine came out,
like it was spring break.
It came out April 1st and I had spring break and my uncle,
I didn't know what I was gonna do with my life.
My uncle sent me up to his house in DC.
He wasn't there to interview for jobs that,
uh,
publicity firms,
PR public relations.
And he said he left a note and he said,
when you get to my house,
my uncle is fairly wealthy.
When you get to my house,
go down to the wine cellar,
uh,
have dinner.
Sit at that table and write out your goals.
We didn't minute that
table.
He's making you have dinner on your own.
My uncle's a,
yeah,
no,
those are very different guy.
Does he have a cook that cooks you?
This dinner?
The chef.
And he's got,
he's very wealthy dude.
So he tells you to sit down and they serve you dinner and he tells you to write
out your goals.
Two bottles,
one,
two bottles of red wine.
And my dad and this room is in the wine soap uncle.
It's in a wine cellar.
You need to become that uncle.
And then he tells me my nephews too young.
Sorry.
That table is from one of the fucking knights of the round table from one of the
under tables from the hobbit.
The boats that land here first.
Roanoke,
Penta.
But it's at all fucking wood table.
It's only this,
it looks Roanoke.
Virginia.
Yeah.
One of the old boats came over.
Hold the captain's table.
A captain's table.
Holy Shit.
It's,
it's literally from like a 1492 Columbus sailed the ocean blue.
That kind of shit.
No,
no,
no.
Probably 17 or 1800 that's when they,
somebody has a 1492
he should get that there.
I don't think that's around anymore.
Come up with that cash,
but it was pulled out of that paper one bro.
You can't get number three.
I'm one of the top three billionaires.
Shut up bitch.
Yeah.
Those old wood and old wood I think evokes it.
You're right.
I was trying to agree with you and I'm way too fucked up to explain my theory
and I just ended up trying to brag about some dinner I had.
This is my idea.
Shit.
No,
it's a good dude.
That's a fascinating story.
You're fucking uncle told you to sit down in a 300 year old table and he was
going to bring his slaves to,
to have a meal prepared for you,
asked you to drink two bottles of wine probably,
you know,
made by people were put to death after it was over so they didn't know the
recipe.
This is fucking secret grape stomping procedure and then you're supposed to
scroll down your goals.
Just doing that,
just doing that.
Just offering that environment where you could sit at this table and someone
would come over dressed like fucking ask Jeeves with like little tail feathers
behind him.
Mr Crusher,
would you like whole Shradda fish would,
you'll filet manual and you're like,
yeah,
and he's bringing over a bottles of wine and he's telling you to write down your
goals.
Just that alone probably is very intimidating.
It's probably not good for you at all.
It's probably the opposite of beneficial.
I'm thinking it probably be really good thing for you,
but I'm probably,
I'm thinking maybe I'll make you go to burning man and stay there for a couple
of years just to gather your thoughts.
You need to get one of those old tables.
Oh tape.
I got an old table and they'll get like I want,
let's see.
Let's play a game.
Who get the oldest fucking table?
Dude,
I have an old table from five years ago that we started the podcast on that.
I'm trying to figure out what to do with weight cause Mrs. Reagan wants it out
of the house.
That round black table that we started the podcast with
with the,
with the stems with the mix.
Yes.
Oh that's a great,
great
table.
You know what I should do at that table?
I should sell that table and I should take the proceeds and give it to my friend
Justin wren and helped the pygmies.
Right.
That would make me,
because I'm sentimental about shit,
unless I could figure out a way to make it beneficial because it will sell that
table.
Will you handle this?
Because I don't have time.
Can I tell you what I,
can I tell you a pain in the ass?
Can I tell you the way I look in the shit off on Jamie?
I would just look at it like that table inspired so much creativity.
I would want it to inspire more creativity as opposed to sell it to auction.
You know what I mean?
I'd want to,
I want to put it back into the creative universe and go,
let's see where it goes.
What do I give it to?
A creative dude.
It fucking kills himself.
Okay.
How about that comedy store?
Yeah.
Right.
Where bring it where?
Tommy's what office.
Oh,
that's good mood.
You know what I should do?
I should pretend somebody bought it for five grand and just send them back and
it just didn't.
What's the most anyone's getting paid for that stupid fucking table.
It's a $50 table.
Nah,
but it's,
it's,
it's probably a hiding or remember it now.
It's a couple hundred bucks.
I can't remember if there was a lazy Susan on with a Lazy Susan
on it or sorry,
I think someone gave it to,
I don't even know where it came from.
I don't know.
Anything would allow that.
I put that back in the creative universe.
I've had some good times on that table I did to shh.
Whoa.
[inaudible] what's up with that stain?
You gotta love that Jamie.
Bob,
that's half and half.
Uh,
uh,
yeah,
it was a great table and fucking motherfucker of a table son.
I Dunno.
We'll figure out a way.
We'll figure out something to do with it,
but I,
but that has five years.
This,
this table has a hundred years of cows being trapped in a fence.
It was like this horror in this table.
It doesn't exist in other tables.
This is a farm table.
I kind of have a farm.
You do know you do.
And I'm real life.
You do.
I kind of have a farm.
I mean,
I don't have any,
um,
I don't have any animals that I eat,
but I have animals that eat their eggs.
Oh.
The animals that I eat are all animals that are wild in a sense.
It's like the best farm.
Like right now I want to give you some moose meat and one of the reasons why I
want to give you some moose meat is I have like 400 fucking pounds of it.
I really did get obsessed when I hear you,
when you get into your things,
there was a period where you,
anyone who talked about psychedelic adventuring,
I got really into because I felt like I was testing the boundaries of anxiety
with like fearful activities and I was like,
why am I so scared of psychedelics?
Like why am I terrified of it?
And there was a period where anytime you talk to anyone about psychedelics,
I get in that now all these hunter dues,
you got the,
I can't,
I'm so bad at names,
but the guy that you talked to,
three dudes Rinella than the one dude who,
I mean Warren.
And then the other guy,
Cameron Hanes,
ignore Cameron Hanes,
that guy.
There's one guy that says,
I know,
what's his name again?
He kept doing the job.
Oh No,
that's timber net.
He's just being silly.
Yeah,
I know.
But like that's who the threes are.
Good.
Do too.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
But I got really into this fucking hunting thing and I was like,
do you want to go hunting?
I'd love to.
Okay,
let's do it.
I'd love to,
most likely I'm going to do a TV show.
We're working on that right now with Steve Ellis company.
Or I take first-timers hunting.
No booze.
Oh,
he's just getting some licensed coffee.
Why have some coffee without some makers?
Just a little bit of the Little Dash Dash.
Come on.
It's the fucking fifth anniversary kid.
Brian,
what's the matter?
Are you scared?
Now?
I just have a lot of shows tonight.
How many shows?
You got?
Three shows.
Tell me about these shows.
Irvine Improv.
Then this other show that's near the earth.
I don't know where it's called though.
And then uh,
no,
no.
Don't give him that because he's not gonna be able to drink that on the way
home.
Get them an actual glass like a gentleman.
Oh,
we've got another glass while she's no gentleman like a little gentleman.
Listen,
this is in peer pressure.
This is celebration,
dude,
dude.
Just got lazy.
Burble trying to get him arrested.
That doesn't help.
It's the same amount of alcohol.
You're like a child.
You look at cat that hides under the fucking couch,
but you Taylor's poking out because little something,
little something.
Salute my brother.
Happy five years.
Hey Bert.
Kreischer powerful Bert Kreischer in the house.
So buys book or or bit torn it,
but when you can afford then by that's,
that's the future,
right?
Joy,
whatever the fuck I put out,
that's the,
that's the future.
This is enough people,
folks.
You know,
things cost five bucks.
There's enough people,
you know,
people keep asking me,
how do you feel about your shows are fucking being bid torrented it's okay.
It really is okay.
If that's the only way you can get it,
get it.
And here's the other thing.
If you get it through bitcoin torrent and you don't like it,
I'm happy.
Didn't pay for it.
I'm way happier that somebody gets something for free and doesn't like it,
then pays for something and likes it.
That sounds like I'm bullshitting you,
but I'm telling you the truth.
The,
if you can slide through life with the least amount of conflicts possible.
That's why you shouldn't,
but fuck without lube.
Why be rude?
Okay.
What is it so hard to get?
Lube is,
it's not like fucking ANAB man.
Tanium like some shit from Avatar.
UNOBTAINIUM it's not the shit wolverines bones are made out of.
Okay?
You can get it everywhere.
Every fucking way you look,
if you have a phone,
okay,
well you,
what you need to do is you needed a Yelp pharmacy.
Okay?
Look for pharmacy.
24 hours.
Look at that cvs point 10 miles.
Go take a left on van.
Owen Day are cvs.
Get you loop,
but fuck someone with sweat.
Yes.
When you look back and you see Elvis with his stupid sunglasses on,
he,
he's like,
oh,
I agree
it's a six to eight but on sweat.
Look at Jimmy Hill,
man.
Ever since then I've been taking a pill to try to recover.
Go down the line.
What would
rosa parks,
I tell you what's better about this table?
Three people on the wall behind me,
only one of them never bought foxhole.
Guarantee a Rosa parks.
It was never involved in that activity.
That's my shirt too.
Just so
you know.
It's really crazy how few people know.
Two one on Jamie to Ma and I'm on Rosa parks.
Very few people know what Rosa parks it looks like when I do this podcast,
people come to the studio.
I have a three mugshots behind me.
One of them is from Jimmy Hendrickson Toronto.
He got busted with heroin and something else.
One of them is the infamous Rosa parks arrest where she got arrested because she
refused to go to the back of the boss,
which,
uh,
African Americans were forced to go to the back of the bus.
When you look at her,
I don't know if it's the lighting or whatever it is,
but a lot of people think she looks Asian and it's six Filipino or someone along
those lines.
And then the other one behind me is Elvis who I don't believe was ever really
arrested.
No,
that's a mock.
Yeah.
This is,
uh,
this is a mugshot from when he met Nixon.
You know,
that famous photo.
He brought a gun on that plane.
Pull that photo up just to make sure we're telling the truth.
Like it's the same clothes that he's wearing.
Elvis meets Nixon.
There's a famous one that I have because I have um,
um,
the Jessica,
the dancing outlaw from the wild and wonderful whites of West Virginia.
It's,
it's hit the,
the devil,
uh,
meeting,
um,
Nixon and Nixon is Jesco and the devil is a,
the dancing outlaw.
The dancing or the devil is expressing you never listen to Hank three.
Fuck yeah.
Hank three's a best.
You go on your podcast.
I would love to get him on my podcast and everyone reach out to hey three and
get them on Joe's pub.
Can I just tell you this?
Sturgill Simpson sent me a fucking text message today.
He's number fucking one in country on iTunes.
I've been telling everybody about Sturgill Simpson.
I went for a period of like,
I'm not bullshit.
And this is the Amazon thing that's stored.
Storage just sent me downloading it right now.
He's number one.
Number two is the fucking,
the definitive collection of Patsy Cline.
Oh,
booed.
That is fucking amazing.
Ooh,
you can't see it.
It's too bright that sturgeon sturgeon is number one on Amazon right now.
By the way,
with it,
no
big record support.
He's done all this shit independently.
That Sturgill right here.
This is his,
uh,
his album.
This shit is number one right now on Amazon.
I swear to God,
if you like any good music,
forget about country.
Cause I know there's a lot of people to go do Rogan.
You'd go fucking get a pretty good book.
Coast,
you're okays,
you asy commentary.
You're kind of biased,
but God damn you fucking taste in music sucks.
Listened to me.
Just if you like any country,
if you like Johnny Cash,
if you don't like Johnny Cash,
you need to kill yourself,
okay?
Or you need to go to the woods and then think about things,
then listen to it again.
And if you still don't like it,
then kill yourself.
But if you view like Johnny Cash,
please listen,
I Sturgill Simpson because what sturgeon is doing is what Johnny's doing is what
Joe Cocker did is what all these motherfuckers did.
They sing from the heart and everybody's heart as different.
Okay.
This is one reason why Sarah Maclaughlin makes you feel bad when you watch that
goddamn commercial with the puppies.
Okay.
Because of her voice.
It's almost like a dirty trick.
Her voice is so powerful.
Nice.
And you washed in a sad little puppy and like,
fuck,
I need to adopt another dog.
Already have two dogs,
three fucking cats.
But you want one,
you want to help out.
Right.
Almost adopted one in Vietnam.
Did you round?
It was by a campfire and it was been a cage by campfire night.
We'd take it out at night and we'd let it sleep with us in bed.
It was in a cage was in the cage at night and he'll put it in the cage.
The people didn't fucking Vietnam.
They also eat them,
so,
so you have this Justin a cage.
It's a very lucky to be in a game in his stomach.
I just bought surge.
I just spot stirred.
You'll Simpson's album.
Everyone.
I just thought of them bought by the first one to the first one is pretty
fucking dope it.
But everyone go online also and rate and review that album because that helps
him keep him on top.
Helps keep people noticing him and do that with my podcast.
I love you guys.
Yes or not.
Um,
definitely do
kind to say we're not high top mountain.
Yeah,
high top mountain was this first one,
which is really good.
You know,
my wife,
uh,
I got it.
I'm,
I'm a big widespread panic fan and so I got a widespread panic and my wife in
the,
the loop of it gone into honey honey band.
Ah,
honey honey is in Cleveland for New Year's Eve.
I just tweeted it,
uh,
go to my Twitter feed and find it.
If you're in town,
you're in Cleveland.
That's where Suzanne's from and you know,
she wants to do it a hometown show.
Go get that.
My wife's obsessed to have really good,
it's like this is good.
Music does a nicest fucking people ever.
Right?
How Nice.
It's been.
He's the nicest guy of all time.
He's just so nice.
He's just so fucking nice and talented.
And so Suzanne,
it just so nice and so talented though.
We've been so lucky,
man.
We've been so lucky and meeting so many cool people.
I like when you have bands on fuck.
Yeah.
Everlast how about Everlast dude,
fuck that damn Everlast is talented.
That's all playing.
Oh and mortal technique.
I'm mortal.
Fuck yeah.
Where's the,
why is Everlast last CD not up in that fucking hand anymore.
Put it back over last fall down.
It's an earthquake.
That album terrorists was amazing.
Yeah.
Do his um,
um,
the uh,
all studio or all acoustic of the,
a life acoustic instead of,
he did a play on a life aquatic and even made a,
his CD cover look like a,
a life aquatic like with his face.
He's just a cool motherfucker got me into a box cutter.
Patsy.
Oh Dude.
Yeah.
I talked to him when I go to Philly.
Vinnie paths.
Yeah,
I talked to Vinnie pads.
Every time I go to Philly I go,
hey everyone tickets.
And we're always like,
oh,
flip schedules.
Yeah.
I've had that issue with him as well.
He's a good dude though.
And I like his shit,
man.
He's a good rapper.
He's a big boxing kind of sore as well.
He knows a lot of shit about boxing.
Yeah man.
That's the beautiful thing about the times we live in,
you know,
times you live in and are connecting us to so many cool people.
You know,
we're,
we're living in strange times,
man.
This is,
this is the time where the boundaries between people are slowly dissolving.
You know,
we're that one radio station on the way to Vegas with podcasting.
We are that one radio station.
Yeah.
It's,
it's like the people that are cool or picking it up and they're like,
and I love when you run into people that are like,
I told you about this a million times,
but like I met these two dudes under a banyan tree and Hawaii and they're like
the machine,
oh fuck.
And we just ended up catching up about your latest bobcat Goldthwait episode and
just bullshitting.
Right.
You know,
that does those things.
It's cool to be a part of this community.
And I don't feel like,
you know,
like podcasting in general with radio lab and with,
with what's going on with the,
with cereal like it.
I haven't paid attention to cereal.
Are you into that?
It's really good.
Keep hearing shit about how being an amazing,
like the really,
it's really good for six,
six episodes and then it falls apart.
It's one point.
It's like Doug,
you and Dunkin go and hunt for Sasquatch.
He's like,
I would have heard of the guy got out.
So I like,
I guess he does it good.
I guess there's,
I guess I know the ending of this a problem,
right?
That's every fucking Ufo show.
Yeah.
Did she ain't find no Ufo.
It's,
by the way,
I'm telling you,
you're a joke.
Cause that when you and Duncan went Humberside yeah.
You said you're a joke is like if they had founded I would've heard about it.
Yeah.
And I,
when you,
I mean,
I think I called Duncan and I was like,
Hey,
just did you find it?
He was like,
burden would be on the news.
We had a good time talking to now we're high as fuck.
Have you watched that show?
If you pay attention and understand and you just watch those episodes where me
and Duncan are wandering through the woods were barbecued.
We're barely conscious.
I love that guy so much.
He's my face.
Well there's no my favorite but he's my favorite.
There's all my favorite.
Joey's my favorite.
You're my favorite.
Well this is a lot of favorites.
Brian's my favorite.
I even love Jamie.
I'll call Dunkin's.
My goto panic is like if you want to freak out when I'm going through shit like
real shit that I
you need to really think about is the fact that man,
we might not even be here.
We might be in some sort of simulation and some alternative dimension.
There might be people looking over his right now deciding whether or not to
delete you.
Do you want it?
I'll give you my example of how g Doug is a genius.
We go,
he comes on to do my park,
I assume to do my hot gas,
and he goes,
sure.
We find the time.
And at the time I was going through the book stuff and I had a panic attack in
the middle.
The podcast,
like five minutes in,
I started spiraling out and this is what I love about Dunkin's brain.
He goes,
he goes,
man,
Hey,
you know,
David Letterman's never grown as an individual.
It's playing the same character.
There's no rules to this shit.
Let's do a guided meditation.
And he'd get leads me through a guided meditation for 20 minutes on my podcast.
He just leaves it,
you're at,
there's a tiger coming out of the river and you're just in your intuit and I and
you pop out on the inside.
You're like,
motherfucker.
I was like,
I met with the Zen Buddhist monks in Japan,
Zen Buddhist monk in Japan.
There'll be did a meditation.
And I told him,
I said,
will you do me a favor?
Check out Dunkin.
Troubled hot.
He told the monks and download Dunkin's.
I told his mom he was a wreck.
He was a,
he was a westernized a tad bit.
He spoke English,
but go checkout Dunkin man,
tell me what you think about this guy because I really
do.
He's got a,
he's got a special thing about the way he processes and I don't know if it's him
having gone through,
you know,
cancer and having to deal with that shit and be us,
you know?
But like he's a,
I've fucking can't say enough about that guy.
He's my goto panic anxiety and he knows it.
So he answers the call.
No,
he's a good dude,
man.
He's a good dude.
Like four months,
Duncan,
I lived together maybe a little bit more than four months.
I forget how many months it was,
but he called me up.
He's like,
dude,
I'm in a motel right now.
My girlfriend kicked me out.
I don't know what I'm going to do.
I go,
come live with me.
let's have fun.
I go,
come on dude.
I got an isolation tank.
There's a gym.
I go,
come on,
come have fun.
So this is like in the height of fear factor.
Dunkin came and lived with me.
Oh,
you live with me for awhile.
You know,
I live with Tate for awhile and live at Dunkin and fascinating.
I don't know him,
but I follow them on Instagram.
Caveman coffee,
ceo.com he seems like he's,
he seems like he's,
he's,
he gives me,
it looks like he doesn't drink,
doesn't smoke to undo and he doesn't,
he's super straight edge.
She lives like a fucking very rewarding early morning cup of coffee life.
Well you know what Tate is?
Tate is a robust and enthusiastic individual.
He's very happy.
Like Tate loves to give people hugs and it gets,
loves to get excited about shit.
That's why he loves coffee.
They need to do,
they need to do a show with him on travel channel called the baby monster where
he just goes into big
because he's a big dude,
but he's a,
he seems like the nicest guy in the world and he just goes to the places where,
you know,
when you draw a prediction about a person,
the way they,
based on their way they look,
but then he just connects with everyone.
I mean,
every picture I see him,
it's like came in with warrior paint with his fucking beard.
He does a lot of movies,
man.
He didn't like that Denzel Washington movies done.
He's done a ton of movies like over the last two years especially.
He's really successful.
Yeah,
he's a super good,
bad guy in movies.
He's cause he said,
he said what a giant dude.
He's scary.
He's up.
He's a sweetie.
He's a really nice guy.
Did was it you and him?
I just retold this story to somebody.
Was it you and him with the guy that was drunk and the elevator and the and the
hard rock hotel.
He didn't just knock on the door.
He pounded on tape before take got to his hotel room.
This dude was telling them that,
you know,
he was like a,
that's my room and take.
It's like opening the door and he's like,
no,
this is my room.
He was like,
I told you it's my fucking room.
I think that's really big too.
She frat looking kid and you know,
Tate's up big guy.
He's like six,
four,
200 and God knows whatever the fuck you ways,
you know,
black beard.
Yeah.
He's a big dude.
So this guy was bigger than Tate.
Like he's such a bully that he's like bullying,
obvious giant people,
you know,
like wow,
are you crazy?
So take goat tape,
gives this guy a free pass,
goes into his room and I'm in the room adjoining him and Eddie Bravo and I are
in the room.
I don't want him were baked as fucks and let us even seems real.
Right?
We're in this hotel room and um,
we hear pounding on the door and you know,
we have adjoining rooms.
So I opened our door and Tate's door was cracked and I pushed Tate store out and
we go into Tate's room and then we'd go out into the hallway and we saw were
exiting out of Tate's room,
you know,
I dunno,
sign of solidarity or some shit.
And then when we did it that way,
but this dude is standing over Tate and he's bigger than Tate.
He's got,
I told you is my fucking room bitch and tastes like a,
I don't know what you're talking about man,
because obviously I have the key.
How did I get the key to your room?
You know,
that kind of shit.
Trying to egos,
you know the guy keeps talking to him and take goes,
why don't you just swing on me,
man?
Come on.
Why don't you swing on me?
And the dude like moves forward.
Tate leg kicks him and then pulls guard.
He says,
oh wow.
And then pulls him down onto them and then all of a sudden throws this dude in
Alma Plata.
And then from the Omoplata,
right when he's got this guy on the ground,
that guy's baffled.
He has no idea what the fuck just happened.
Somehow or another through the shittiest luck of all time.
This is six foot six giant man who's been pushing people around.
His whole 22 years on this planet has run into the wrong mother fucker in a
hotel lobby while he's drunk at the hard rock cafe in Vegas.
So Tate pulls,
pulls an Omoplata off on this guy,
and he's got this guy face down,
all of his weight on them hipped out.
And these,
these fucking security guards show up out of nowhere.
And they go,
Whoa,
whoa.
Slow down.
I go,
dude.
don't worry.
It's fine.
And the guy goes,
you're the fear factor guy.
And I go,
yeah,
what's up man?
I go,
listen,
it's fine.
He's just sealing to choke him to sleep.
Tate says he's just going to choke him to sell.
When I say he's just gonna choke him,
sleep tape says,
okay,
so take just transitions from the Omoplata to the rear.
Naked choke.
Chokes this guy completely unconscious.
Don't head down his friends who had been with him the entire time apologizing
forum.
We're happy node who's beating them up?
Pick this guy up.
He's like,
what happened?
What happened?
They push them into an elevator and he disappears.
They push them into this elevator and the doors closed and this guy vanishes and
we never see this guy again.
And this is the end.
Taten never heard him.
He never punched him.
He all he did.
Even when he kicked him,
he only kicked him to get the guy to react and then pull them like you kicked
him light.
He just hit him with a light inside leg kick and Tate was so confident about it.
It was just coming off of the ultimate fighter.
He's just fighting professional fighters.
A couple of weeks ago,
leg kicks.
This guy dragged him to the ground.
Okay.
I'm obsessed with small details and stories.
They make a story for me.
My favorite parts of this story,
okay,
is that you guys are sharing adjoining rooms.
Eddie Bravo's there.
I love that.
I love that because what you have is a coach at that story.
I love that you say a subtle leg kick
and then he throws him into an Omoplata like the fact that that makes a story
still fucking good and then when this card comes up,
you go Madorie my friends,
a professional fighter,
he's just going to put him to sleep.
He didn't say that.
I didn't say he was a professional firm.
Whatever you want is not going to get hurt.
He's just going to put them to sleep.
Oh.
And when I say just going to put them in,
and it all started because the dude said something and then Tate said somethin
like relax dude.
And the guy backed away.
And then Eddie Bravo,
any bravo goes,
you're the one who's talking shit.
And then backing up.
Oh,
and when he said that,
because Eddie kind of instigated it a little bit,
the guy got what's coming.
Don't get me wrong,
because the guy was the one that told Tate,
that was his room.
The guy was the one who banged on the door.
But when take came out of the room was zero fear in his eyes and a slight smirk.
I think the dude,
even through his drunk and Hayes was going,
I might've just stuck my fucking hand in the wrong bees.
I've done that.
You've got into a fight with a guy in that he smiles you see as a dope races and
you're like,
oh,
I'm fucking dope.
Make you vulnerable.
Why would adult braces be assigned?
That's a sign of vanity.
Oh,
you don't read people the way I do.
I'd be confident in that.
I saw if I saw a grown man with adult braces,
I be like,
what about your nose?
No,
we're going to do about your ears once you fix your teeth.
So it's just a weird headlines sign.
I'm gonna fuck you up.
I read it as a guy whose kids didn't care about his dad and mom didn't care
about a smile so they didn't care about slapping him around.
So he's tougher than me.
Like I got an appliance when I was like eight.
So like I look at it the opposite way.
I look at like,
I remember the kid that didn't get appliances and braces and they were the kids
who parents let them smoke cigarettes and I was like,
Oh fuck that.
I'm not fucking with that guy.
That's interesting.
Yeah,
I read it opposite.
Hey,
can you do okay?
I know you're going to,
I know you're not gonna like this idea it sometimes I keep talking sometimes,
like sometimes I pitch,
sometimes I feel like I say,
I read you when I shouldn't read you,
but then I,
okay,
what?
Just me or everybody you specifically,
you're the most,
you're like a fucking squirrel.
I can never figure out where you're going.
I go,
I go the Joe,
Joe will think this is funny.
And then I say it and then you go,
why?
Why would you say that?
And then I go fuck.
But okay,
here's my thought.
What if you did like an entourage show but with her stop right now.
What do I say?
No shows mother fucker.
Hold on.
Stop.
Actually back it up.
Pack it up.
Let me just look at pitch it please.
It's still ours.
What about,
what about like 10 years ago,
but he didn't years ago.
Yeah,
like I don't want it now,
but like a 10 years ago where you cast it,
you ride it,
but about your life off your factor with hanging out with mixed martial artists
live in the wild like pot times,
early beginnings of fame.
Much like entourage,
which I was a fan of a,
maybe not everyone was nothing cause this one as well as the time I pitched the
snake,
the snake Tamer to Russell Simmons make taint.
No,
wouldn't that be,
I'd like to see that.
These old stories and they were only have a tank.
Just a line.
Is this nice of Dick?
How does snakes fuck?
I'll top of each other,
I think.
I think they have an internal Dick.
Yeah.
It goes into their body,
but it comes out.
I'm sure you guys are so tactical thing.
You guys should probably teach science courses.
Fucking blue bird cry.
You wouldn't do that for my friend wouldn't do a scripted show.
It'd be drinking maker's mark.
No,
I'm done,
dude.
I'm done.
No,
just produce it.
Not starting over.
It's over.
Why?
Because anytime I'm spending producing a television show is time that I'm not
playing freeze tag with my kids.
I'm not doing it.
Okay.
I got enough time in this world.
I'm doing podcasts.
I'm doing a UFC commentary.
I'm doing standup comedy and sleeping.
I just love those old stories.
Don't be scared.
homey.com
to get some ice.
Yeah.
I've no desire to be involved in anything scripted ever again.
I'm doing a,
you know,
I'm doing an episode of Mark Marin's show coming up.
I'm psyched about that.
I'll do like little episodes of shit,
but
there's a lot of things I want to do.
Man.
I want to be a pilot.
I want to fucking go to the moon.
I'm going to fucking wrestle hires.
How about,
how about I would love to learn how to fly planes.
I just don't have the time.
It's a lot.
I get obsessed with shit very easily,
so my,
my problem is never not having things to do.
My problem is never being bored.
My promise.
The total opposite.
My problem is God damn is not enough time to do everything.
There's not enough time to do everything.
It does feel like that.
I wanted to learn how to fly helicopters after beating New Zealand.
Have you seen bill burns new special for everybody who is listening to this
podcast?
Please.
I am apologetic to the extreme right now.
I know I've been repetitive about this.
I love when someone does a special that is legit funny and bill burrs new
special is legit funny and he's got a bit about fucking helicopters.
One of the funniest silly is goofiest bits.
I love it.
It's a fucking great.
It released the day I went to Tokyo and I was going to,
I bought,
yours was the last one I bought.
I get it on.
It's super simple.
Go on comedy central.com I got yours actually
download mine.
Right?
Netflix doesn't let you download it.
You have to stream it so you can't like load it on my iPad mini.
I got to know my opinion.
Netflix lets you do that.
Comedy Central.
It was the link.
Codeine.
Yeah.
Yeah,
but I'm saying Bill Burns is on Netflix and I don't think Netflix,
I think they just said recently,
they're not going to allow you to ever watch things offline.
Right.
It's not the case.
That's unfortunate.
It's an unfortunate,
well yeah,
you've got to get me an offering,
but planes.
What about fucking
planes to our watch everything.
Can you load it up?
Can you load bill's podcast up and then buffer it up on a plane?
Can you load?
You can't do it.
You can download,
you can download it,
but you can't download it because you can't watch online.
You have to stream it.
So if you're flying Australia,
you couldn't watch something on Netflix.
I can see yours.
I had years.
All My,
I get a download mine,
you pay five bucks,
you own it,
it's yours.
And it came to end.
It didn't take that right now unless you,
unless they have it also on iTunes.
Air will be available later.
Probably on.
Yeah,
but I got a year later.
I feel like,
I feel like I'm waiting out the,
the,
the wave to find out how the fuck to do an hour these days.
Cause I don't know,
it's like we,
everyone was like,
oh put it online for five bucks like Louis C K and now it's like,
oh everyone does Netflix.
Oh you can't watch it online and do it on comedy.
I liked the,
I liked the fact that yours,
the way yours was done for me personally as a user was the light more user
friendly?
Well,
the reason why I did this latest one with both is because I knew my,
for the last one I did.
It was,
it was good to release it online.
Yeah.
It was good to release it online.
And do the five buck thing and it made all its money back.
But then the,
and it made some money,
but then I sold it to comedy central so it made more money.
But the comedy central model,
the way they're doing it now allows you to do both.
They put it on regular television and then they have an uncensored 18 minutes
longer on the internet.
That's what I want.
I don't want the one,
I don't know.
It's perfect.
It's bought.
But you might,
I mean he,
look,
it's good to have it like flipping through the channels and they catch you're
special and you're killing.
They go,
Holy Shit.
Burt crushers.
Fucking hilarious.
And then you submit a scalpel.
I saw his special a lot two nights ago.
I couldn't sleep a man cave and it was on.
And I said,
you know,
I don't think I've ever seen them live.
I did the same.
Well I have seen him live,
but I did the same thing I was watching on showtime in my hotel room and I was
like,
Holy Shit,
this is a really good special fucking really good at texting.
We text him,
text him now,
but she said his brilliance is in its simplicity.
I let's go.
Keep going.
Keep going forward.
Yeah.
Well he's a funny dude.
He's a good dude too.
But the point being that I know him already and I already know he's funny and I
enjoyed it.
Watching it on TV.
Randomly flipping through the dials.
Boom.
Look at Sebastian.
Okay,
let's see what Sebastian's up to and I watched special.
Really good.
Uh,
yeah.
I Dunno.
My next hour special is going to be at the DC Improv at 11:00 AM in the morning.
What a good idea.
It's my call in sick to work tour.
That's the appropriate response.
This is just shit idea for people who work out.
I bet it has.
What you want to generate some fucking people on welfare and your aunt and your
audience.
No,
I go and do right.
Unemployment and I,
and I drink it radio sometimes and then I go right to often times.
Sometimes a lot of times.
But yeah,
I've been calling in sick to work show.
It's been selling out everywhere you,
you,
she even knew an 11:00 AM shows all the time.
Shows all over the country.
You're serious.
I mean dead serious.
I thought you were joking.
No,
first of all was in DC.
Sold out in 20 minutes.
That's it.
We're doing comedy during the day though.
I mean the clubs like identical to the night.
The only thing I'm afraid is I'm not giving them something different enough.
So like in Pittsburgh,
uh,
came like 30 tickets away from selling out.
Mitch Fatel came in and did a set and we all dressed in matching.
I wish I,
and maybe I'm overthinking it,
but I feel like there should be something more for an 11:00 AM show.
But it's like Saint Patty's day,
it's like,
why can't say Patty's I'd love to,
okay,
I'm taking this shit to the next level.
I need to find a spot to do a 5:00 AM show for 28 Nope,
5:00 AM four 20 is passe.
Do it.
I'm tired of this and Joe,
Joe,
I don't want you to be able to stay awake toe.
I want you to have to get out.
Joe,
do you know what my show is?
You're taking away the brilliance of that idea,
which you just said is genius.
I want to set my alarm to wake up to have something to look forward to.
Yeah.
But really bizarre.
Like everybody there knows they fucked up and everybody knows that they got
there at 5:00 AM no or did they share 5:00 AM Joe Rogan in Edmonton?
Edmonton.
That's it.
Let's just say,
let's say dairy.
How Algorithms people have jobs then we need to do this in America.
Can't be in Canada where it's called Denver 5:00 AM show.
No you do with Denver.
It's gotta be somewhere weird like Albuquerque.
Okay.
But there's no comedy club in Albuquerque,
so we're going to have to do so many weirder.
Somewhere weirder.
Like Nashville,
South Dakota,
Nashville,
five in the morning,
5:00 AM show,
Hank sandwiches,
coughing,
Prozac.
But,
but the best exam,
which is you've ever had in Nashville and Mimosas?
No.
The best egg sandwiches you've ever had.
Um,
from the Rogan residents.
Cause I have chickens that wander around and they pick grass and they have yet
they have these eggs.
And have this dark orange yolk that tastes delicious.
You don't even know what eggs tastes like.
Here's what's the one,
some city slicker eggs thing.
Dot.
All you'll pale blond yolks.
Best thing of Vietnam was their egg sandwiches.
We're light crispy Vietnamese breads with two over easy eggs dumped inside it
with this hot sauce.
That was amazing.
Best things I've ever had.
I've aight fuck.
I'm going to bring in the Vietnamese woman to your house to make egg sandwiches.
Guess what?
You're not.
You can bring into my house.
She was doing that.
Teaching.
That chick where I live,
teach you good.
He wears the camera trying to skull you.
Can you move it another way?
I try to do something.
One of the party,
you want to,
you want to smoke a joint and the travel channel doesn't let you know.
I don't know.
Your slave masters prohibit you from certain unauthorized Madison plant plant
medicines.
Even when the federal government is,
the federal government has recently relaxed.
All of it's a legislation when it comes to medical marijuana,
which by the way,
we all have prescriptions and you do I think by proxy
I will self diagnose you.
Intranet physician believed need marijuana.
I feel it's important for almost everything you do and everything that you do
without marijuana is to the detriment of the human race.
I just keep thinking of this fucking owl thing and the guy standing outside
Gelson's and people are coming to a bird feed,
slapping it out of their hands.
What the fuck you doing?
They're like,
and the guy pulls me aside.
He goes,
hey man,
there's another way we can go down threes.
Some asshole of one of those two handed saws.
Fucking pioneer.
I love this fucking life pilgrim,
which is shitty.
So you have,
you seen these new dude,
there's these new fucking um,
these new machines that,
that uh,
they cut the tree,
they strip all of the branches off the tree,
all the bark off the tree.
They saw it in the sections and drop it.
Have you seen these days pull,
pull these things up?
There's these new machines that they use and it's almost unfair.
It's like
I've been talking about this lately,
like we have a weird hierarchy when it comes to animals and cause fish.
We don't think of necessarily a fish as animals.
The way we think of is like lamb or cow or Patrice O'Neal side.
They weren't what?
They don't have eyebrows.
He said you can't see them look at you like,
oh,
what the fuck are you?
That's so true.
That's really true.
Well,
they're not.
You know,
they don't live in our world.
The thing about fish,
they live in that weird world that we shared,
a wet world.
I mean,
if I'm going to eat anybody,
I'm going to eat some dude from another planet,
right?
If I'm going to eat,
a person becomes between eating.
Some guy lives down the street from me or eating some guy lives on Avatar.
I'm going to leave.
I'm going to eat the advocate.
What is this?
This is one of the machines.
There's a few different kinds of,
no,
no.
Not Anymore.
The tree,
grabs a tree,
pulls it out of the ground,
cuts it in half.
It's true.
I mean all on the spot.
It's the most I've seen that were just,
yeah,
it's crazy.
It's,
it's almost unfair.
It's almost unfair how it does it,
but anyway,
the way we treat fish is so different than the way we treat any animal.
If we had,
if there was a video of people taking cows in a net and just scooping them up
with like tanks,
they roll tanks across the field,
drag these nets,
scoop these cows up for hoist him up in the air,
suffocate him,
just suffocate him.
Did it mean we kill the fish?
They don't even kill tuna.
They just let him die.
They don't kill him.
They pull them out of the water and go,
yeah,
I guess that's it.
Maybe have a bullet in the brain.
Aw Man,
boats are expensive.
You got to suffocate.
Hey,
in a couple minutes we'll be dead as fuck.
So don't sweat it.
We just pull them out of the water.
Can you imagine if we just,
every time someone killed a cow that killed it with a pillow,
do you want how much people would freak out?
The visual of just dumping visually dumping cows onto the flat.
Just like a big boat.
Oh Dude,
outrage.
Oh my God.
People would freak out if you had a boat,
but it was on tractor wheels and it was in the middle of a corn
feeling when you're scooping cows up and dropping them on their fucking heads,
people would freak out.
But the same people
I would say,
and we meet and he
animals but occasionally has see she,
if my blood feels thin,
some Sushi cause they don't,
we don't think of fish as being the same as
a deer.
A beautiful deer.
I've definitely,
it's a thing you're talking about taking it first time hunters out.
I've definitely caught fish and kill fish and flood them and scale them.
You don't feel bad at all right now?
I have no remorse.
Uh,
however,
I was around someone when they killed a buffalo and it was weird.
Stark like I was like,
I don't know if I,
I don't know where whatever happened to the trees that were pulling you two
guys.
One fish.
No,
I don't want to watch it and stop.
I want to see this.
Come on man.
Don't take matters into your own hands.
The fucking video.
So we were just talking.
I love the way Brian's non sequitur brain words.
He goes two guys,
one vision.
Have you seen that?
Yeah.
There's nothing to do with where we're talking about.
And you know what's so funny is that there are things that we're trying to find
like a really profound video on the,
like the efficiency of these machines that are chopping down logs.
It's like,
it's almost like you're watching and going,
whoa,
whoa.
It's too fast.
It's supposed to be an ax.
It's supposed to take time.
This is a life form.
You don't respect it if forum feeling thousands of them.
Yeah,
yeah.
That's the machine.
Yeah.
I'll find that shit in a video.
It's a Gif.
Watch.
This dude is fucking crazy.
Look,
it cuts the machine or the machine cuts the log at this.
It's shrimps.
It and just start sewing it into fucking sections.
It's crazy.
It cuts it in.
Literally two seconds.
Lifts this giant tree in the air.
This tractor arms strips these logs of branches and then saws it into like 20
foot or 12 foot sections,
whatever the fuck they are.
Whatever the name of that machinist.
I've had that blowjob.
Wow.
Just Tifi.
Just wrong.
You need to complain before it cuts your Dick off.
You need to complain like as it starts,
it's process of
I'm not good [inaudible] my needs.
If we did what we do to fish to any animal,
people would freak out.
We have a weird hierarchy.
We could probably do it to hamsters.
No.
People love mammals.
There's something weird,
but why can't we do it to dolphins then?
Is it cause they make noises.
They're smart,
but no,
no,
but is it really smart?
No,
no buddy.
Buddy knows the same.
Like,
like a shark dies on the deck of a boat.
Nolan.
They go,
you know?
Yeah.
We had to catch a big shark.
There was killing people.
Fish die.
But dolphins make noises and whales do too.
I wonder if that's why those are the two animals that society is a verse to
killing better in the water.
You know what I mean?
If will they're,
they're mammals were,
were averse to killing all the mammals.
Oh,
your first killing whales and Orcas and seals and sea lions.
Anything that's a mammal that breeds air.
We have an affinity to things that breathe.
The same shit that we've read were really weird.
Like things he could breathe underwater.
Like,
ah,
you bitches,
you and I even out
freshmen.
I mean,
if,
what is the difference for you to fucking see a lot of tuna?
Can someone tell me a seal smarter than they used tools.
They have language.
Did he use emojis?
They fucking have Facebook pages.
They're dirty.
Conti animals with goofy teeth.
Okay.
What's the difference between them and some Angler fish or a tuna or a halibut?
Nothing.
Life forms that aren't people,
but when you beat them,
they cry.
That's what it is to seals cry when you beat him.
I'm thinking of walruses.
No bs horses are inherently more country than seals because my teeth,
teeth privilege,
they have teeth privilege.
It's white privilege and it's long and it's hard.
It's both.
It's teeth,
white,
white teeth privilege,
which is worse than even regular white privilege.
I always see life could be like breathing.
You can't feel bad for things with fangs.
Can you imagine like all like all things like all fish and I'll see life could
breathe in space and then you could just hike half like fish swimming around.
Imagine fish could just pop out of the ocean.
Just shoot right up to them.
You got it high enough it just went to the moon.
You're like
all night long had a slingshot sufficiently powerful enough that can launch a
fucking big mouth bass.
What?
It was only like one,
it was only 35 feet and you just were sitting with your friends.
Like
we'd sort of take it for granted that the earth's atmosphere is what,
like 300 miles or something like that of air 300 miles up.
It's just fucking space,
right?
Like that's where the space station is.
It's all like 200 plus miles up.
But imagine if it wasn't 200 miles,
just a mile.
I'll go out.
You have to do is you get that fish a mile,
that'd be awesome.
Super slingshot that shoots fucking northern pike a mile into the sky.
And once you do,
they just swim around the earth.
Yeah,
and then they just swim in space like there were travelers.
I,
you'll see dolphins swimming the hours.
The best
part of that is like after you slid it up that 13 seconds later we were like,
is it gonna hit the ground?
You can have an APP that would trace the fish that you put the little badge on.
Put a drop cam on your fish.
You could track your fish.
You can check your fucking stupid slingshot fishing flies around the earth.
And imagine if things didn't starve to death.
If they could just live off space air.
Why not?
Why do you have to eat things?
Who said it says,
how come fucking plants aren't eaten?
Shit.
They're just sucking things out of the dirt.
How about you learning to suck shit at a space?
Stupid.
Your mouth stretches out and you become just like a big micro meatier suction
cup.
Just sucking and fucking space.
Dust and radiation.
You live off radiation.
We were like a caterpillar.
We need just start a Kickstarter for this.
Yeah,
you would change.
You Morph once you go into space.
Imagine if we found that out,
that people go into space that we can live,
but we've become a totally different thing.
We become some weird micro media or a micro media rather.
A Suction Cup were just up there floating around like a jellyfish.
It'll be universe sucking particles and radiation out of Scott.
Pitch it to me though,
like this is what it is.
You think it caterpillar,
when a caterpillar is live and it's funky ass caterpillar live [inaudible]
leaves and shit.
Do you think those motherfuckers know one day that'd be flying?
If they did,
they'd be like,
can I apply now?
What am I now?
What about now?
No,
you don't ever get to talk to them.
To stupid.
Caterpillar is just keep eating your leaves like your,
your genes dictate and one day you'll huddle up in a little cocoon and pop out
of magnificent floating literally a ferry.
I mean,
what's the difference between a ferry and a butterfly?
Fairies are stupid.
That's the difference.
Butterfly.
You can see what happens.
Ferries aren't even makes sense.
W do they die?
Why they die?
Their magic can't figure out a way to make them live forever.
How did the ferries fuck with new ferries?
Come from fairies come with too many problems.
Okay,
but butterflies,
even in the gestation process and the process of becoming a butterfly from being
caterpillar,
it's nothing but beautiful.
Nature is nothing but cocoons and and breaking free and the moment,
the first,
the first wings flutter and then launching itself instinctively into the and
just flying around as a butterfly,
knowing what does it have like four or five days until it dies of old age.
If it's lucky,
who knows?
What does a butterfly lived to be a month,
but differences in Maine four days,
20 days,
it's not a year.
They don't live that long.
They die quick as fuck.
They don't even care.
They just just followed through with that process and the reward is literally
being able to negotiate until through three d space and this exuberant sort of
orgasm orgasmic way that you'll never experience as a fucking lowly human being.
With bones and flesh.
They just fly,
fly from plant to plant,
sucking nectar out.
Would you trade
it?
Nope.
Hold on.
Here were the pitch at all.
I'll tell you right now.
What about you get 40 years of your life in the last 30 you are technically the
human version of the butterfly.
You can fly you,
you,
you feel a hundred percent perfect.
You can dive into water and Doug does the deeper your magical for 30 years.
So the keep waiting for him but you got to do some gay shit.
It is.
That's where it like whenever but you to have to be a fairy decks like the whole
time.
No,
but like would you trade,
you can only breathe through Dick's three quarters of your life.
You don't necessarily have to stop death,
but you got to breathe through Dick's.
Are you in terror through us?
I'm like,
well you tearing through space.
You got to find decks in space.
They contain oxygen.
That's what it just big,
giant,
juicy Dixon are attached to clouds.
Oh good Lord.
Blocking me.
Oh someone make a Gif of that big clouds.
Big giant takes a test to clouds.
You're sucking on the fucking station to station as you float through heaven.
I'm sure there's people out there offended right now.
I don't.
I think there are people a lot.
I'm with you.
Whatever's happened on the show burden.
I didn't plan it.
Nope.
We're not happy about it.
It's not what we expected.
Ooh.
We were hoping for some stories about Vietnam.
I called Bert up the other day.
This is how rare bird crisis.
What are you doing man?
Ride motorcycles.
A Vietnam.
There's not a single person I know where I can call them up in the middle of the
day.
I go,
what's up,
dude?
What are you doing man?
Oh,
riding motorcycles.
Vietnam
was the fuck says that Bert Kreischer.
Every time I called Bert,
Oh,
I'm on a roller coaster in Angola.
I'm on top of a mountain on a zip
one.
Woo.
Felt like Mr
Mr. Bird.
Woo.
That is a real conversation.
Is it not?
I called you up.
You said you're riding motorcycles and Vietnam.
It was very real.
There was a,
yeah,
it was.
I listed off like nine different things I'd done with last week and you were
like,
what the fuck the fuck you kept going.
I keep,
forget the word you used them,
but I loved it.
You were like,
Ah,
you're a madman.
You're a,
you're a madman,
you're a madman.
You live in the life of a man,
man.
You're out there fucking
going to different countries almost every month experiencing some wild,
crazy shit,
dude.
You're jumping on a fucking planes and you're on.
There's animals involved and your behavior.
There's a lot of shit going
down,
dude.
You're doing a lot of crazy trips.
It's been scuba diving.
Scuba diving was the one that fucked me up the most deep.
Did you go red crusher?
What the Fuck Bert Kreischer.
That's a big space.
There was a wreck down there.
A boat,
very similar to the one that I got off on.
There was a fucking boat.
That's a fucking daunting thought.
You're getting off a boat looking at a boat that failed,
gone up
every,
the last time I saw this,
it was all panic like that.
This isn't boats last moment.
This is she,
I'm going to a fucking wreck.
Won't a place of terror.
It's like visiting a crime scene.
Where was this again?
A Fiji.
Fiji and they bring us out.
Horrible weather.
Well you're the boat crash.
Uh,
forties I think everything in around Fiji.
Christ,
everything has to do with World War II.
Wow.
So,
uh,
so yeah,
we dates stormy weather's six foot seas and we get in the water and it's,
I would say like if you,
if you think you'd love scuba diving,
you'd love scuba diving,
but if you think you may not enjoy it,
you'll fucking hate it.
Like it is not one of those for the faint of heart.
Yeah.
But you are a guy.
This is,
this is a fascinating thing about your man.
You're a guy who's had your anxiety issues.
You've talked about it,
this Bert Kreischer lean and mean looking sexy as
the hair loss,
but yet you do a lot of like really crazy shit.
You'd do a lot of like wild trips with these people to show triplet brings you
all over the world.
Like you're doing.
Like some things that you would think that someone who would have anxiety or,
or who would think about all the variables in life and kind of panic a little
bit.
You wouldn't be drawn to this,
but you,
you excel at this so you're,
you're in a lot of ways.
You're a,
you're a contradiction,
Matt.
Your contradiction.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I can't figure it out.
I wish I can figure you out in a way.
Oh,
okay.
I'm going to tell you something about you.
Okay.
You're this like really happy go lucky guy,
but you're also very combative.
I saw you play pool when you play pool.
You wanted to wait.
You wanted to win right now?
No,
no,
no.
Little bit of bird is bullshit.
A little bit of bird is bullshit.
You're,
you're being kind.
You're being kind.
You're a sweetheart of a guy,
but you're like,
Hey,
who cares who wins?
You want to fucking win,
dude.
Right.
Am I right?
I noticed it.
No,
there's not.
There's not like a,
there's a fire in your eyes.
I was like,
Ooh.
I have the thing,
the same thing you have where I go,
I don't know.
This is a horrible time.
No,
no,
no.
It was a horrible,
listen,
I'll give you,
I'll give you way better.
I had a really hard time liking people if I lost them in anything until it was
almost 30 I really had a hard,
I,
I didn't like
people.
If I lost them,
I didn't like them.
Like I couldn't be your friend.
Like if we played chess and you,
you beat me in chess.
I wanted to kill you.
It's retarded.
It's so like,
it's so dopey and it's like such a really bad way of managing thoughts.
So I connect with that.
All I'm saying is you wanted to win a game of pool.
Weird way.
Cause I can I tell you what I did.
By the way.
This is way,
this is way not how bad you want to win that game.
Bert Kreischer I am afraid that I,
are you afraid of your Father Bert?
Why?
What about the time he pissed on the table?
The father in law's table.
He's pissing,
you're afraid.
Come on man.
You wanted to win that game,
dude.
I know one dudes want to win.
I like,
Ooh,
smelled hot in here.
I do.
This is a horrible conversation.
Good conversation.
Drop it.
Oh No,
no,
no.
Listen,
you're a beautiful human being.
I'm not calling you out.
Know what I'm,
what I'm saying is when I say a little bit of birds bullshit,
it's like there's a reason why you're such a funny guy.
He's a reason why you're such a,
a good comic.
And one of the reasons why is because you're sold likable.
You know,
you'll like,
so ingratiating,
you're such a good guy,
but you're not a pushover.
Like there's a reason why you're successful too,
is like,
you know when to be nice and when did we not nice.
And when you engage you in a little game,
that's when you get to see,
oh,
there's a fire under the hood of Bert Kreischer.
We played one game of paying.
No,
that's what's so exciting about it.
I,
I have empathized with,
like,
I'm going to say this,
I'm,
I'm just be honest,
I empathize with guys like Todd glass where I feel like sometimes I hear him on
podcasts and he is the butt of every joke.
And I always constantly know that Todd isn't that he's a super talented dude
who's amazing on and off with the nice guys in the world.
I think my fear at of,
at in college was I wasn't this dude who like,
I'm not that guy that's like two girls,
one chick.
Fuck yeah,
that's not me.
But I also felt like that took something away.
Girls.
One check is three girls.
Yeah.
One of them.
I already talked to you about the thing,
two guys and a check.
But that's not me.
I can't do that.
I'm not,
I've never been had that are not in my DNA and I,
but I've,
I've always felt like,
uh,
like I do there.
If you're not competitive,
you're not male.
And,
and I,
I never want people to think I'm a really nice guy,
but I never want to think about pushover that you could steal from.
Yeah.
But sadly and and way too fucked up to have this conversation.
I feel like that I am that guy that I've been so nice that I've been taken
advantage of.
But you have,
and I know you have,
cause we've,
we've talked about people that you are friends with or you've had bad
experiences with and
you know,
I,
I don't think there's anything wrong with being competitive I think,
and not only that,
I think being competitive as good for everybody around you because I think that
especially if you're competitive,
like with a a game or something like that,
you're trying to get better at the game and another guy was trying to get better
at the game.
When you start doing that,
it,
it fires up your intensity level.
Like it doesn't necessarily have to be a negative thing,
right?
We Associated William negative thing.
If you fall short,
if you fall short,
you assume you'll want to blame it on the other person instead of blaming it on
yourself.
But if like we play pool and I miss a shot and you run eight balls and you sink
the nine ball and you win,
that is not,
if not all I did was fuck up,
you did amazing shit.
I should be psyched.
Like you should be psyched.
And she'd be like,
wow man,
I got to step it up.
But some guys like this mother Fucker,
you feel it and it's,
it's literally thought management thing.
I know people who look at life that way
and this is this like the a little bit of a shot back and they start barking and
they think their bark is important and,
and we both been guilty.
Everyone in this room's Miguel to do that,
right?
Yes.
Right.
100% that's a,
that's,
that's a natural human behavior.
Especially when you're young.
And some guys even,
you know,
it's like 10 years is not as much time as you think it is.
Everybody wants to think it's a long time.
And it can be if you're in jail,
if you're in a bad job or a shit relationship,
10 years can take a long time.
But it also can be incredibly quick.
And what you learned in a 10 year span is like,
you know,
it's not that much.
Sometimes some,
some people,
you know,
especially when you're busy,
you don't really don't really grow that much in 10 fucking years.
True.
There's the,
the,
the capacity you have not to grow in a three year period is shocking.
Especially if you're busy.
If you're busy,
especially if you're busy doing some shit you don't necessarily want to do,
but there's nothing bro.
Point being there's nothing wrong with being competitive.
Well,
the,
the real problem is getting upset at people who are better than you and shit.
You should be happy.
That's me.
I celebrate everyone.
But there is a competitive bone in my,
but like I say,
Bill Burke told a joke on,
um,
Conan about cancer that was really out there.
Was it turning the Lance Armstrong rat was talking about,
no,
it's,
I'm trying to,
having ball cancer.
No,
it was,
it was an bill.
I'm sure I'm fucking this up,
but I appreciate the joke is that,
uh,
the fact that the NFL is now going to take over cancer in the middle of the
game,
they shut it down and then they stop for a moment,
sounds for cancer,
and then they start the game back up and I'm supposed to be there and he goes,
I would never do that in a fucking living room.
My buddy,
like,
stop the movie and Go,
Hey,
my dad died of pancreatic and let's start it back up again.
Now I'll tell you this,
it's a great fucking,
it's something that I've seen a ton of and thought a ton of,
but I haven't thought of.
Now my competitiveness is not what bill burr.
I respect Wilbur beyond a doubt.
I would just wish you had thought you had already thought of the idea.
You just never did anything with it.
And that doesn't go look at,
this is gonna sound clunky,
but that doesn't go away.
The more
manual I will always respect my friends.
And,
and,
and I say some guys that I don't talk to that much,
but Daniel Tosh,
I will always respect the way he writes jokes.
Also in my head,
I'm concerned that my joke writing it is,
isn't a par with his or that my work ethic and that's where I fail.
My work ethic isn't to part with his arm.
I was stand up,
his work ethic is,
is beyond mine,
but our party levels at par.
And so I definitely look at Doug's like an inspiration.
I go,
how do I get to where Doug's that to where I'm partying like really hard but
writing but still writing.
I mean I just,
I feel like,
I feel like I'm going to sabbatical with this trip flip.
And,
and you said this to me the other day and now I'm hammered.
You said this to me of the day you go,
uh,
I said,
yeah,
I drink a bottle of champagne.
You said if you,
I just grabbed the glass.
It wasn't there.
You said,
are you writing about this shit that you're doing?
Cause I told him a few things I did and I was like,
ah,
you got to write about it.
You should be talking about it on stage.
You're,
your act would be so unique.
I who the fuck is going to talk about riding motorcycles to Vietnam or Jamie?
Show him the,
the,
any show him the rope swing I did in Utah in Moab.
I mean,
I like,
are we saying this in air quotes or is it a real,
I was feeling the lava lamp.
I was filling the lava lamp.
But if you're going to the rope swing,
no,
you hanging onto it.
Can I tell you what I thought?
I thought I have superhuman powers.
Then I could feel the lava lamp from far away and I was like,
mm.
Probably going to do it just turns out it's hot.
Well that's super human powers.
Fucking that's it.
Not that Straw.
I love the slightly superhuman,
this part of your life.
Every part.
This is,
we did this.
Whoa,
what is this?
This guy's bring,
uh,
he's young.
Go back.
Go back to young.
Is there we're not supposed to no,
no,
no.
This is what we did with this.
Will this get us pulled from youtube?
Is that why you guys doing this?
But maybe then what are you doing?
You're on like a rope.
It's a Kenyon swing.
Oh my God.
That's the corona arts.
You're swinging off of like a bungee cord or some shit.
It's a rope.
It's a climbing rope to climb on roofs.
Fog.
Zach Christ.
Yeah,
Bert Kreischer.
Why I scare people like this?
I don't,
you know,
my breaks and you go flying through the air if it breaks,
they tell you not to wear helmets.
They're like,
you don't want what happened.
Oh,
you're right.
You just want to die.
Just die.
This guy,
Devin supertramp,
it really is fantastic fast.
He gone when the slope at least 80 miles an hour.
I mean,
he's this Christ dude.
Oh my God.
But yeah,
this,
uh,
this whole whole season has been really insane shit like this where you just are
like,
fuck that.
Yeah,
your skydive and you're doing all kinds of nutty shit,
man.
But you get in touch.
The inner paranoia.
Do you get in touch with the,
I wish I didn't feminize this,
but the little bitch in your heart that goes,
that goes,
hey man,
what are we doing?
And you're like,
Oh hell fucking know the little bitch in your heart.
Like that should be the title of your next special.
You should do this.
You should do your next special all on these crazy vacations and then call your
next special,
the little bitch and your heart and just talk about the terror that you
experienced on a semi weekly basis.
But it's what's going on here.
Bert Kreischer.
Oh,
this is a,
we did this,
it's called the terror of death.
It was on,
it aired last week.
The chair of death.
It's a 420 foot free fall,
a rope swing in the Zealand.
Rope swings are the best band.
If I could open up a rope swing company,
and if you're out there in any,
you guys are listening,
you're,
I know how great this,
this,
the reach of the show works.
I want to get into rope swings like they're fucking next level.
There's so much more fun than Bungee.
So much more safer than unattached.
All worried about them breaking.
No,
no,
no.
Trust your equipment.
Nope.
I don't worry.
Cause if you start worrying Joe,
you're up at 2:00 AM and fucking New Zealand spiraling out in the shower
thinking I got bigger things than this.
Yeah,
it's deep.
That is.
It is.
So what happens here that you on slide back explained this to the people who are
just audio,
which is like,
so it's a percent of the people.
It is literally a diving board.
490 feet above.
So you're sitting,
this woman is sitting in a chair with her back to the edge of this platform that
is Manny hundreds of feet over the ground.
Imagine sitting on the back of a diving board at at 500 feet over the ground.
Right?
And you are pushing your own chair backwards,
like you're in your office and your casual relaxing until you go over too far.
And then what these guys are doing on the ledge is that stopper.
They stopped for about nine times.
So she feels like she may fall next stopper and then they bring her back and go,
hey,
whoa,
whoa.
What are you doing it?
So how far does she fall?
Uh,
the,
the stats are on there.
Um,
I think it's four 2,420 feet.
Yeah.
What the fuck it is hindering 20 theme free.
I'll be real honest.
Freefall at four 20 is a moment when you're done.
We were like,
I mean they're dead and in heaven or,
that was the greatest thing I ever fucking did in my life.
Oh my God.
Let me do it with you.
I did the show.
We shot clay pigeons with you.
No worry whatsoever about the repercussions.
I'll tell you why.
Some shotguns at some pellets or some,
uh,
disks.
I was really fun.
Was Fun,
man.
Shotgunning um,
like shooting shotguns at disks is really fun.
It's really hard to judge.
Like if you never shot a shotgun before,
I might've shot a shotgun like maybe once or twice ever before I did that.
And so doing it was really,
it was interesting.
It's like the like you think about those people that like the the people that
were shooting guns like way back in the day,
there's sites where so like archaic.
The idea was just like there was like a point that you had a lineup with an this
thing at the end and that's how you like looked and he tried to figure out and
you had to shoot a lot of shots.
Now you get these goddamn super powerful optics and you just get that cross here
on it.
As long as you don't flinch,
just pull and squeeze the trigger.
Boom.
Most of them are pretty God damn accurate but like shotguns,
like shotguns is just down the barrel.
Things are flying,
things are moving and the shotgun doesn't shoot as fast as a bullet.
It's not like you can just hold it in place and like it has like a slightly
slower projectile it up in front.
You kind of kind of anticipate where the bird is going to be or the clay pigeon
is going to be when the shells or when the pellet's rather in the air,
so you have to almost lead it.
It's a really interesting,
it's fun.
It's a,
it's,
it's what I respect in bow hunting.
My Buddy Russell Matthews when we grew up was a big time bow hunter compound bow
has him and his dad went every weekend and that's the only person that I've ever
shot compound bows with.
But uh,
but the,
the,
the
artistry of bow hunting that you,
you need one area and it's to hit it in and it's,
it's fucking heat at the moment.
It's very different than pulling a gun up and just pull the trigger.
It's,
it's definitely your cell phone out,
your wallet,
your keys.
It's like getting your shit together.
They're arguing against it though,
is that if you don't know what you're doing,
you're more likely to wound an animal.
Which I really agree with that.
I agree with that.
It is,
I mean it's,
it's legit.
Like I think you have a bigger responsibility if you want to try bow hunting
then you do.
If you want to try rifle hunting.
Cause if you hit an animal in the body with a rifle,
most likely it's dead.
It's if you have a real high powered rifle,
it's going to hit the body.
Even if you're not perfectly where the heart is or perfectly where the lungs
are,
it's going to blow through everything.
I think he's going down most likely.
But with a Arrow man,
you can like launch an Arrow into an animal shoulder blade and they get dig into
the bone and stick there and then animal runs away with three legs.
You gotta be super careful.
You got to be really diligent.
It's what my wife is a redneck that all hunters and her family and she calls it
cave time when an animal gets stuck by an Arrow and it doesn't know how to help
help itself.
So it goes to the cave and tries to,
it's where most animals that die is they go to the cave to try to like,
like I need to nest,
but like when I get hurt emotionally,
my wife would go,
oh,
you need some cake.
Like you're a fucking elk.
The neck in neck,
Bab.
And I'm like,
Oh yeah,
you have to be really sure.
There's a
easy animated Gif file from one of the most recent podcasts threads,
whether it's Moose.
This guy shoots his Arrow with the Moose and it's hard to tell because
it's a Gif.
It's on High Rez,
so it's hard to tell where the Arrow goes,
but it looks like the Arrow might actually just rock it off.
The fucking antlers of the Mousse.
It either rockets off,
the antlers are sticks into his shoulders,
but he charges at this dude like that's the guy,
right?
He asked me,
he might not be because they might've been more than one person there because
there was a guy who was filming it.
He wasn't filming it.
Most likely he was shooting,
unless it was a Gopro that was on his bow or it could be dead.
Have you ever ate pigeons and no,
but you know,
pigeons were brought over to North America for food.
They were brought over by people from Europe that a regularly ate them is food.
We consider them to be pasts and rats with wings.
Like if you go to cities and pigeons are shitting all over people's cars and
shitting all over people.
In Manhattan,
people think of him,
it's passed,
but they were literally brought to North America as an invasive species
specifically to harvest them for food down and test.
And actually a lot of them got,
yeah,
a lot of them got loose and a lot of them became,
you know,
Pharell and now they are what they are now,
which is like you go to New York City,
you have flocks of these,
essentially they're wild pigs.
It just fly through the sky.
I mean,
they're this weird sort of creature that people brought up.
We just assume that they're natural.
They're not at all.
They were brought over here for food.
Oh Wow.
They're not native to North America at all.
Good.
Really?
Yeah.
Squad.
If you've ever had squad,
you rather have a squad.
Squad has pigeon.
I found all this out through Steve or Rinella brought over here as food.
I'm going to put them on a Google,
those two vanilla.
I'll tell you one thing about him.
He reads insane fucking books about animals and wildlife and soap.
Well,
he's had a lifetime of being immersed,
but it's small details about stuff.
I literally just fucking sit there like,
how the fuck the New York City pigeon rescue central.
That's a place to meet girls that cry.
I feel like,
man,
I don't have enough crying chicks in my life.
I'm kidding.
I don't mean that.
If you're working there and you're angry and you thinking about blogging on
Tumbler,
please don't.
I don't mean it.
I'm glad you helping these pigeons.
They're cute.
I think pins are adorable.
Um,
I do,
I've never eaten a pigeon.
I think they're cute.
A lot of people did man pigeons,
but pigeons were brought over here for food.
They were brought over here a long fucking time ago.
Italians.
Yeah.
They're brought over here in the 16 hundreds from Europe in,
um,
in Europe and Canada as well.
It's amazing.
You know,
pigeons could fly 50 miles an hour.
Wow.
Yeah.
Some dude on Wikipedia,
he fuck.
He's like,
who are you?
And the lack of data and it's in the yard.
Just talk to me about to give a person a pigeon,
a ticket
in Burbank.
There's wild parrots,
like a gang of wild parrots.
Oh yeah,
I've seen them.
Wow.
And they,
it's the loudest thing ever out of nowhere.
It sounds like murder outside of your house.
Whoa.
That's weird.
Yeah.
And,
and if you look online,
there's websites devoted to them and stuff and they look just like normal
parrots,
but they just go around in this huge gang and just that's present green.
I remember we,
uh,
worked at the,
um,
West Palm Beach Improv,
the old one way back in the day.
And uh,
I
they put you up at this condo is me and Maddie Kirsch and we looked out the
window and it's fucking like parrots,
like actual parents on this power line.
I'm like,
dude,
there's like real parrots out here.
Like this is the weirdest shit ever.
Like their parakeets and parents.
And I'm like,
these are like tropical birds.
Like Miami's tropics.
It is the tropics.
It is a tropics.
Yeah.
Barely America.
Right.
Let's be realistic.
It's too awesome to be America.
Too crazy.
And too many Cubans got in and just made it tropical.
Tropical.
We're going to Cuba,
Cuba,
do a trip to Cuba.
Oh Dude,
I want to kill opened up relations as well.
The best thing about the show right now.
Yeah.
I would love to.
Those parakeets are parents.
What are those?
He said the Burbank parrots.
Yeah.
These are actual words.
Actual parrots.
Yeah.
And you have to come from down because of Youtube.
What?
I know,
these are just still pictures.
Oh,
did they come from people that were,
uh,
that had him as pat,
sir.
What'd they come from?
You know,
they,
there's no,
there's just rumors because Disney's,
there said,
lot of people think that Walt Disney's,
it was Walt Disney's parrots and he just hasn't shown,
we find out they're fake.
They're not parents.
Walt Disney is such a motherfucker.
He's got fake parents out there flying around.
Shitting on people.
Yeah.
I had a bird.
I had bird feeders out I bought recently and they found out about it and now
they won't leave my house alone.
They're there like every day you amaze that.
There's a cool dude.
That's pretty dope.
Yeah.
They're loud.
Too loud.
They're annoying as fuck.
But didn't hear floods on.
Put that,
let them into your spiritual compass.
Yeah.
Bringing them into your center.
I will.
That seems like an amazing thing to have in your neighborhood,
man.
Oh,
that's cool.
It's really cool because it's a,
I live in a question place,
so there's horses and parrots.
It must smell awesome.
Horse Shit and bird shit all stewed up together and the Burbank son.
How is it that it's illegal if you don't clean up after your dog,
but you're allowed to just have your fucking horse shit everywhere.
Just empty.
It's giant asshole.
1200 pound body of stewed grasses.
Brian,
I'm sorry.
Is this cobblestone?
Is this a dirt road?
You farmer?
Fuck.
Pick up after that donkey.
Your donkey.
Just shit all over my previous
dog.
He's not that green.
This is contributing to global warming
donkey with his dirty ass all it.
Brian said he didn't like Paris in his day.
He's in bed with a check and he's like the bears out the back.
Like I never said this.
Oh my God.
Of course.
I always work on
bringing the fucking parrots into the courthouse.
We would now like to call prosecution witness the Burbank Paris.
I've never said this before.
No roofing.
What are you talking about?
You
know,
two heads is fine.
I take two hits all the time and I drive
ingrown hair.
You know,
all you need to do is you need to Douche with that stuff.
Like plants
kills everything.
How about,
how about the,
the defense attorney and the judge goes badgering,
badgering the witness in the objection and then brush.
He goes,
hmm.
Probably want to Greg too far too far.
Judge Rosenthal would like to ask the bird a few questions about its owners use
of
antisemetic language.
That's just gonna say NF.
Yeah.
AndF word.
Could you imagine fucking fucking burger?
What's the bird?
Just combined a bunch of sentences and everybody took it as fact.
Like,
hey,
did you guys forget this bird can't fucking talk.
I see a lot of shit.
I'm repetitive.
You know,
fucking you don't.
If I say,
look,
I hate assholes,
but Jews are awesome.
And then this parrot goes,
I hate awesome asshole Jews that pat fucked up the meaning behind everything I
stand for.
This parrot has got me on a goddamn stairs.
Can't even cross examine this fucking shitty parents
back to my guards niggers.
This parrot is fucking doing me in.
Could you imagine the parent is what you'd be like?
I can't fucking believe we live in a world where I can get convicted from the
ramblings of a fucking thing.
They can't even talk back.
How was it parrot?
Hey Parrot,
what's one plus one?
Okay.
If I asked a retard what one plus one is,
he couldn't answer me.
I'm not going to let him prosecute.
I'm not going to let him cross examine people.
And when I,
when I say retired army and anybody with a disease,
just something,
somebody really fucking stupid.
No diseases,
regular,
regular genetics.
Oh No,
no,
no chromosomal issues.
Right?
I think it's the flip side of like something happens and yours,
uh,
Lance said it about her cousin today and it was,
it's actually mentally backwards.
Slow,
retarded.
Now growing quick enough,
we were at the firm,
whatever until six in the morning about the fever and that's what happened to
her cousin.
And that's how that conversation started.
I hope that one day retards like smallpox.
There's some shit that we look back on and we go,
wow,
back in the day,
like people were idiots.
And when I say retards again,
I do not mean a person with a disease.
And I mean people with Down Syndrome,
I mean just idiots.
Just morons.
Like those God hates fags.
People on the corner waving their flags,
those are retards.
Okay.
Yeah,
it'd be beautiful if one day we cracked the code to what makes a person worth
being around and there's no more retards.
Well,
I think when would run out of them,
I think we're close to that corner because I think,
I think you obviously don't go online that much.
No,
I think those people don't know.
But I think the people that really matter,
the people that are going to stop saying,
please don't use that word,
have realized that that word is a tad bit outdated and that whatever their child
is,
is categorized into another,
uh,
a shade of gray.
Ah,
I wish I wasn't talking about this right now.
I know what you're talking about.
But I think,
I think the parents who go,
my son's not retarded.
And I know what they used to call that ass,
but that doesn't apply to me.
I get what you're saying.
I think they're showing up soon.
Does that make sense?
Well,
no,
I see what you're saying.
Um,
I think that the idea of calling somebody a derogatory term that's eventually
going to get phased out.
So just like
we've abandoned a host of other words over the last 2030 years.
There was words that were used on television on a regular basis during like the
Fred Sanford Day,
Sanford and son that you could never put on network TV today.
But I think ultimately that's what the word retard.
I mean,
if I'm going to be really honest,
that's what it feels like.
It feels like a word with a shelf life and gets worse.
We got to get your licks in now while it's barely acceptable and justify them as
he can and then just like cast it aside and then hope to paint a similar picture
and in different way.
But it's like all of these mean words,
whether they're derogatory terms for homosexuals or different ethnicities or
whatever the fuck it is.
All those mean terms,
it's like that's kind of what being,
what's being filtered out and we feel really to look at it objectively if you
stand back and try to take the whole thing in.
I think that what we're trying to do is somehow or another through a back door
get people to be nicer.
And one of the ways is to get them to stop saying things that aren't nice to
whether it's uh,
you know,
ethnic slurs or derogatory terms for gay people or derogatory terms for,
fill in the blank.
You know,
what,
whatever minority or whatever marginalized group you are like that's,
we're trying to prevent that.
So ultimately that's what it is.
Like even if it gets out of hand or people get too politically correct about it,
like what is,
what's the root of it all?
The root of it all seems pretty positive because the root of it all is like
trying to eliminate hate,
are trying to eliminate pain or trying to eliminate discomfort.
It seems to be that's what the root of it all is,
which is,
it's hard to argue against.
Right?
Yeah.
How are we,
sorry,
I was listening.
Ah,
uh,
skill back later.
See what's that?
What is that?
Oh,
I don't have a problem with guys hit on me.
I know,
I know.
I got it.
I got,
I made a meme.
Welcome to the world.
The Internet.
I still enjoy bird squirts.
Burt squared stock car.
Yeah.
This is still up.
I think so.
Sure it is.
I get to people as you shows going burden scores,
they're just trying to score a snow machine.
Beat you in a unique way.
I love it.
I love that unique touch where you get to.
Got All right.
Let's are we close to wrapping this up?
I think we probably should sober you up.
We got five more minutes ago.
What do you wanna talk about?
Um,
Joe Cocker Dude,
his cock rocky mountain high.
That's not Joe Cocker.
Yeah,
it is.
Oh,
I'm thinking of Joe Walsh,
I'm sure.
Walsh.
Joe Walsh.
Rocky mountain high.
Yeah.
Best drinking over Denver.
Infrast great fucking song with a fucking cocktail looking out over the
mountains.
Bash on rocky mountain way.
But yeah.
God,
thank God damn song.
Brian,
can you play it?
It does have the legal.
Are you fucking serious?
I wish you a smaller,
strange,
or
you show he also wrote the beginning of a,
of a string eagle song about cocaine on the Malibu Hotel,
California.
Nope.
Uh,
uh,
damn.
God Damn it.
Uh,
cocaine on Malibu.
What?
Cocaine.
Oh,
Malibu is one of my favorite quotes ever.
Okay.
Uh,
the lead singer of,
I've got to find the name of the song while I do this.
The lead singer of the eagles.
Glen Fry.
Yeah.
What was the other one?
There's two.
There's two of them though.
They both a Guy Glen Fry,
Joe Walsh.
Who were the other people?
Um,
there was a huge star.
It's find out who's the eagles like yeah,
there was that one guy that did Miami Vice.
Yeah.
Who was that?
That guy?
Yeah.
Who was that man.
Okay.
He's in this band.
Uh,
I hate that people already know the answer.
Don Henley.
Don Henley,
that Don Henley wrote one township county.
See,
remember the fucking,
remember the dude,
I got it over.
Do you remember the dude from?
Um,
uh,
what's that fucking movie I have beside?
It's in my head and I'm never going to remember it again.
Joe,
do you want me to fucking bowling movie?
What's the bowling movie?
No,
no,
no.
The one with the Jesus is a
big Lebowski.
Big Lebowski.
Thank you very much.
I haven't hates the eagles I have in my head.
I remember he hated the dude.
Hated Ego.
Aw Man.
I fucking hate the eagles.
Zhi The cab was playing the eagles.
He got mad.
He'd say,
hey,
either banned.
You can't fucking hate on the eagles.
Don Henley is in a car.
This isn't that documentary that's on agency.
A whole math question.
And he's driving three miles per hour with a cloud deck.
He's only got 40 more yards or he needs a sucker clown deck cloud Dick to keep
moving.
Yeah.
Someone's going to make an animated Gif file of air stations.
Just giant,
big black dicks dudes have to suck.
They're wearing space suits.
I don't even know her.
Don Henley.
Desperado no,
stop.
Just let me fucking please get this out of my mouth.
Please just swallow it.
Don't stop it.
Don't be scared.
Okay.
I feel like I'm getting comedically,
uh,
assaulted.
Fucked.
So Donna fucking Don Henley's Stanley,
I'm heavily is in a car with a,
it's in the fucking documentary.
Don Henley's in a car with the drug dealer is holding a lot of weight and
they're flying that you say,
wait,
I'm quoting,
I'm quoting him.
He said it in that doc.
You got to see the documentary.
It's really good.
It's on HBO.
And he says to the drug dealer,
he goes,
ah.
He goes,
hey man,
slow down.
And the drug,
you would looked over him like real quick and goes,
hey man,
life in the fast lane.
And then he heard that.
He goes,
that's a good title.
I want those moments in life where you go singing.
Like,
just like who said,
what's the best job for killing?
How else?
Right.
It was perfect fucking moments.
I am way too fucked up.
We should wrap this up.
No,
it's a good point.
If I was a guy who worked in the fucking logging industry,
I'd probably be at owl assassin,
motherfucking house.
It's just kill them all.
And they'd be like,
now what are you going to do?
Listen,
there's no hours.
Let's get it over with.
It's just fucking start chopping trees.
There's nowhere else.
This is how assassin has been here.
He can't,
can't assassinate Alice,
but tuna.
You can suffocate those bitches and rope nets,
pull them out of the fucking world in which they live and dangled them in the
air and mother and crush the ones at the bottom who literally gets suffocated
first by the weight of the thousands of others.
Everybody in their own way howling for that sweet,
sweet ocean water till the moon oxygen.
Massive tune of just felt like crying a little girls
kills it.
Horrible of pulling oxygen out of the regular atmosphere,
needs water to stay alive and it knows the water's right there and they can't
chew through within that
another topic.
Oh,
I see what you're saying.
He's trying to get you to drink.
So he's trying to do so fucking hammered and it really is weird that we treat
tuna that way.
That's kind of fucked up.
Yeah.
Everybody agrees.
Just treat tuna like shit.
I like the way you look at it.
Like if you flip it on its ear,
just like the owl problems are the thing with the pygmies in Africa.
Let's come up with vocal mechanism that we can feed the tuna that can make them
vocalize what hurts
when you put them in the nets,
they go,
sorry.
No one would kill tuna if they talked to you when you killed them.
What if they were assholes?
Lift.
Two of them are like,
and when his shit
like nets net scooping them when nuts.
Fuck him.
I hate him.
Suffocate in the air.
Pull them out of the sky with a Cardigan to your ass.
Huh?
As you're pulling them out of the water,
they're like,
you're fucking quit all your quiz.
I fight you.
I fade all your fucking hall malls managed to suck my tuna is whole
sod being fought out of my tuna asshole.
Denied everybody.
Anything to add?
What did there to,
hey,
look at me.
Look at me.
I know you're looking at me,
dad.
You are suck.
Suck a dick.
You fucking quit.
Now you understand me?
I might suffocate,
but I'm up here suffocating like a man,
like a man.
You're going to look to you guys when fish.
I know you're not going to watch.
It's great.
Shut your hole.
Hungry for it.
I love this product.
I love what we do.
This is so much fucking very fun.
It's very fun.
Love it.
Thank you so much for being anxious.
Thank you.
Letting me be bored.
You're you're correct.
You're correct.
That's true.
You need to not drive right now.
Whatever you do,
Uber the shit out of it.
All right.
Um,
that's it for this week
because this is a holiday week.
Ladies and Gentlemen,
Chris missed is here.
So celebrate by trying to get high off a m Anita miscarry mushroom.
I've never heard anybody who's been successful.
So it might be bullshit or it might be like you got to get it in the right spot
at the right time of the year.
But
good luck.
Anyway,
merry Christmas.
See you next week.
You fucks.
We got a lot of really exciting guests.
Um,
thank you for five years.
Brian Red Ban.
Anything to say?
Five fucking years.
Five years and a lot of fun.
Lots of fun.
Uh,
never anticipated it lasting this long.
Can't believe what it has become.
A must stay plugged in a half to help to get it all out.
Otherwise be stuck with thoughts in head and no one,
no other recourse.
Can I just say,
I wish you were drunk every episode that way.
Can't do that.
That's not,
that's not special that way then it becomes an alcoholic hour.
I love this.
I love this world.
Are we harming?
We're humming and the alcoholic three hour show or a thank you everybody.
No,
no bullshit.
Aside from the bottom of my heart,
my heart,
everybody that's ever been a part of this.
Thank you everybody who's ever done any of the episodes or people that listen,
they're all of it.
It's crazy.
We're all,
you know,
Brian and I might be the ones that are like somehow or another at the,
the front of this,
this connective chain,
but we're all in this weird thing together by some strange way.
And uh,
you know,
and Bert Kreischer you're part of it.
You fuck anything we're saying?
Oh,
thank you so much for letting me be a part of it.
I didn't let you do shit.
No,
I was having to be funny and I like it.
I,
this has been a blast this life.
Fucking rock.
Fucking
the rocks for you too.
Thank you for five fucking awesome years.
And,
uh,
we'll keep this party role in bitches.
We're not stopping to the boat hits the rocks hollow.
Larry's did.
There's so much funny shit like that.